foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to round two of the
Tata steel chess tournament 2022 my name
is Fiona style Anthony and I'm delighted
to be joined once again by Grandmaster
Robert has Robert welcome how are you
today
there's nothing better than it
absolutely and we've got plenty more
games to look forward to today but first
let's have a look at what happened
during the first round yesterday so we
had three decisive results as we see the
first players arriving into the playing
Hall in the background uh young Kristoff
do that beat Richard to report but it
Gujarati in the longest game of the day
beat Sam shankland and last year's
winner Jordan went for race he beat Nils
grendelius all the other games were
drawn some more exciting than others but
a lot of interesting stuff happening
yesterday and Robert let's look at the
standings after round one
as you said three decisive games we have
Jordan Von Forest he's just taken off
where he left a year ago he beat news
grandiose in the final round in 2021 he
beats him in the first round of 2022
we'll see if he can continue this but
vidy Gujarati he was able to grind out a
very nice technical end game against Sam
Shanklin so I was impressed with vidit
and of course Duda he's the World Cup
champion the vice champion at the world
Blitz no surprises when he's doing well
in any event Fiona absolutely uh so
these three players will keep a close
eye on today let's see who they are
facing let's have a look at the pairings
for today so our tree leaders fitted
will be playing Fabiano caruana so
that's an interesting one
um Duda will be black against pregnant
Nanda who did great yesterday holding
kiwi to a draw with black and finally
Jordan van Forest will be black against
Richard report and then I think Robert
let's talk about two other standout
clashes Magnus Carlson will be playing
with the white pieces against the Local
Hero Anish giri and of course Mary you
can tell us a few words about the
Intrigue behind kariakin against duboff
I see you once again putting me on the
spot well when it comes to Magnus
Carlsen Niche gear we know how much fun
they have with each other on Twitter
always just giving each other friendly
Jabs but Magnus Carlson the white pieces
he's not going to be friendly today he
was solid enough with the black pieces
yesterday today against Anish who drew
the lowest rated player in the field we
know Magnus he wants to win every single
game he plays he wants to reach 2900
we'll see if he can start that Journey
today and the other matchup that you put
me on the spot for Fiona karyakin and
dubov oh boy dubov had one of the games
of the year when he beat Sergey kariakin
in the Russian Championship but that's
not why you asked me the question I know
it's the off the board stuff because
kariakin he criticized dubo was very
vocal about saying how could you betray
our Russian Nation by working with
Carlson and not janapamnashi the offer
wasn't there we'll see what happens
today Fiona but I yeah I know it's going
to be very very dicey between those two
I don't think they're on the best of
terms absolutely and Robert well you let
us know in a second how the chat can get
involved as well but before I do before
we do that I saw you were in the chat
yourself and you promised our viewers
that if they watched the show they would
get your prediction as to how many
decisive games we will have today so
what is it going to be how many decisive
games today
hmm how many decisive games well should
I let them vote first or should I just
say uh I think we'll get three decisive
games again I think three is a good
number uh the games have been fighting
even those that end in premature draws
don't want to talk about that anymore
that was hard but if you want to worry
about you
yeah well let's go I'll try and trumpet
I'll go with four a lot of a lot of
fight today let's see it let's let's
call for four you say three and well
Robert how can our viewers get involved
as well
well they can get involved with the vote
anytime they would like you go to
chess.com events navigate to the
tournament select a game click vote and
select your winner you can win a piece
of the 1 000 prize pool for best voters
or free Diamond memberships voting ends
after the 10th move of each game so do
not miss out and remember to vote on all
the games you want to earn those prizes
I'm not eligible Fiona is neither star
if you don't know if they told you this
but either way we're gonna head to break
and when return we'll break down what's
about to happen in round two
foreign
[Music]
welcome back as round two has just
gotten underway here in vacancy we saw a
handshake in the game between
Andreas panko Robert is that where you
would like to start or where do you want
to start
um I mean it's hard to choose because I
haven't even seen the first moves yet
from most of the games however Mama jar
with the white pieces always an exciting
player we know that yesterday he took
that early draw it wasn't early in terms
of move number but considering how
interesting that Clash was you know I
still feel upset about it so watching
his game today I'll have to get over it
I am a big fan of his chess and of
course yes of pankos as well but I just
don't want to see any draw first today
so what can Shakira do what he has to do
today is to play a beautiful game
ideally it ends decisively he wins or
loses and that's where he'll make it up
to you
he can draw it's okay the result is fine
just so long as it doesn't happen
abruptly when we're all watching on the
edge of our seats with just seconds on
the clock but you know we're gonna get
past that and by we I know it's it's on
me uh but I think we'll learn a lot more
when we see how quickly he's playing and
what line he's choosing because even on
move three right now right like he can
choose Knight C3 he can choose Knight F3
and oh oh
no way Robert he's making it up to you
already
did he just play G4
no he didn't
oh I forgive you shock I forgive you you
just played G4 is that even a move
I think he's played this kind of G4
before but I don't know if in this
position like I know that this G4 I
don't know I think my good friend Simon
Williams has played I think on move two
D4 Knight F6 at G4 which I think is
known as the Kilkenny Gambit uh in this
move forward I haven't quite seen it
before but wow what do we make of this
Robert
you know I'm behind the scenes looking
it up and I found a game from 2019 with
an 1850 playing against a 2360. so
that's the one game I see and black
chose the move D5 in that game and I can
understand why you wouldn't take the
pawn but it Free Pawn right Fiona just
Knight takes G4 give me that and sorry
Robert but did you see Anthony panko has
a small smile on his face like he was
just looking at the point like oh my God
I I mean he's probably scared let's be
honest because like G4 happens and
you're like wait I probably should take
that right that's a a Gambit it's a
sacrifice and you can take gambits often
you just allow your opponent some quick
development so Knight takes G4 I expect
to move E4 to be played hitting the
Knight on G4 three wonderful Pawns in
the center on the fourth rank so Fiona
would you take the pawn on G4 I mean I
was just thinking about it like as I
said I've spent quite a lot of time with
Simon talking me through D4 Knight F6 uh
G4 and talking about the merits of that
move
um I think I
I would feel like I should probably take
the pawn but I'm terrified to take it
um and I think it's very likely that
Izzy panko is going to invest quite a
lot of uh quite a lot of time here into
his decision and I know I've avoided
your question I probably would chicken I
did not take it what would you do Robert
it's difficult because you're playing
mom and jar of in this context and
you're like I I can't do it he's such a
tactical player he is so strong but when
we look at this position I think we
should explain why you would or wouldn't
take it so we see the three pawns on the
fourth rank that doesn't look great for
black but you have extra material now
your night's under attack how would you
go about in defending that night let's
say you just say I'm gonna Retreat my
night I'm gonna take my material and run
this is where problems arise because
when white pushes this Pawn to E5 your
knight very likely is going to have to
return back to G8 because the queen
covers squares G4 and H5 so if E5
happens that Knight could get caught and
that's not what black wants to see so at
the very least white has more space
but black will have an extra pawn and
keep that extra Pawn however fewer pawns
mean more open files at some point white
would put a rook on G1 so if black was
intending on casting that way you could
be walking into an attack
you know I'm going to answer the
question I think that he
will take the pawn yeah I I've one while
you were talking I was thinking the
problem with not taking the pawn is that
the position doesn't really get any less
dangerous I mean if you don't take the
Ponder Pawn is still on G4 it's ready to
come to G5 at the H Pawn could start
coming forward as well so it's not that
uh that it's a Gambit that if you
decline it
um you can get a safe position like this
game is going to be wild no matter what
and also if you don't take it in a way
you kind of justify I mean first of all
also you I think you give your opponent
confidence if you don't take the pawn
because it shows that you're a little
bit afraid so I think maybe maybe I
changed my mind and maybe you just then
as the chat was saying take the pawn and
think later
no no you can't do that that's not how
these top level events work you take the
pawn you might regret it and chakra is
going to punish you
um one thing you said I think that makes
a lot of sense Fiona is that when
somebody plays like for an attack and
plays like this you need to start
thinking start diving into calculations
but also the best way to Parry off an
attack is to play in the center that's
what we're often told and the previous
game that we referenced was D5 and that
move also makes a lot of sense because
it's not like G5 by itself is that scary
white needs some time because let's say
D5 and then white says oh I'm just going
to keep pushing that g Pawn this Knight
comes into E4 and well as that Knight
upset to be there I don't think so the
pawn on G5 is under attack Bishop B4
check is a huge threat and the Knight
lives on
yeah but I I don't envy the task of yesi
panko right now also I mean we talked
plenty about uh the disappointing draw
yesterday in Shakira my media was game
but let's not forget that
um none of us were probably as
disappointed as shahya himself
um from the position he had he was
certainly not happy
um only to get half a point so I think
he will have been the the main uh the
main person to be disappointed but
clearly today he's coming out all guns
blazing and I'm really really excited
for this game
no I think that's a very fair point and
sometimes that can lead a player to
playing too provocatively I'm not saying
G4 is that it's just the third move of
the game but when you missed your
chances to score victory in what was a
very decisive position that does rattle
some players so we'll see how shock
continues here I'm super excited for uh
this game and we could go down some
concrete lines but maybe since the start
of the round we can just venture to all
the games just so we can see what's
ahead of us yeah maybe we can even go to
the birds View and uh and see if we have
any more craziness like this one in any
other games so here we are and Robert
um is there anything that instantly
catches your eye here
yeah what catches my eye is this I don't
know if you've seen this game Fiona but
there's a move G4 on the board so
um
uh well the other games are going down
more trodden paths so it's not like
they're unique just yet the game between
Carlson and Geary does interest me quite
a lot actually
um it's not the same as the mama jar of
game with aggressive intentions and a
pawn sacrifice there is a pawn sacrifice
in that game though so in the top left
and we can actually even pull that game
up and start analyzing it this is a
known opening in the Catalan but black
is up a pawn right now and has just
given up the bishop here so we can walk
through the opening moves Fiona you can
of course stop whenever you see an
interesting or maybe even before we get
there so you already said Catalan you
said Pawn sacrifice do you smell some
duboff influence here already maybe
I guess I do smell what The do Bob is
cooking and the Catalan is one of his
main weapons we saw him play upon
sacrifice in a fin Keto kingside Bishop
positioned yesterday against Mama Jarvis
did not look very good honestly but it's
still the creativity that dubov has is
really unparalleled in these types of
positions and so I I do think to answer
your question Fiona that Magnus he still
has so much prep to use from his match
against Jan abomishi
absolutely
and we saw some very calm play to start
Bishop G2 castles castles and here we
see D takes C4 so at this moment there
are many choices uh for white you can
play Queen C2 we know that 95 ideas are
possible Queen can go to A4 as well but
instead Magnus chooses to move Knight A3
Knight C3 in fact is even more popular
than Knight A3 and yet Knight A3 makes a
lot of sense because you're trying to
win this Pawn back with an undeveloped
piece or previously undeveloped piece
and black says you know what I'm not
going to give you the pawn I'm going to
take on A3 but Fiona I'm a bishop pair
guy myself what do you think like would
you take this Knight on A3 or the bishop
pair is what you prefer yeah it's a very
tough question to answer first of all
the bishop for me on E7 has already
moved ones uh so it would be different
if the bishop was still back on f8 so a
piece that's already developed and the
bishop on top of that here giving up for
the Knight on the other hand of course
it's always tempting to create these uh
doubled isolated pawns on the a file and
hold on for now uh to your to your C
Four Points I think the very
double-edged
decision and I think Anish actually
spent a bit of time he spent two and a
half minutes
on his uh on his decision
to take it'd be curious to know is any
still familiar with these lines or what
was this more an over the board
um decision I guess he would have seen
similar
positions
um
would I have done the same is really
hard to to say
um because it's just so tough to know
what has Magnus cooked up here even this
move A4 I mean Magnus has just made that
move maybe you can try and explain what
the idea behind that is a move that at
first sight uh maybe seems a little bit
strange right to make a pawn move rather
than continue development or at least
making a pawn move in the center
I think strange is a good word for this
entire position Fiona because when we
talk about what would we tell students I
would say I don't know if I would like
you to get into this position yourself
because white is down upon has double
isolated a pawns right on The Rook file
there and just is choosing not to
develop the pieces however the move A4
it takes away the B5 Square in case
black had any ideas of trying to keep
that pawn on C4 and also opens up the A3
Square for the bishop so you doubled
your pawns but you got rid of a B Pawn
now the A3 Square can be white and for
this bishop and that hits the Rook on f8
that's a pretty long diagonal and you
didn't know maybe G5 or F4 both those
squares looked fine but not necessarily
great so I do like this move A4 it gives
white a bit more flexibility that said I
like the response Bishop to C6 when
there's a fan keto cattle and Bishop I
normally am a bit nervous about it but
here in particular the move Bishop sees
6 fights for the diagonal and white will
not be able to take it there's no way to
cover the E4 Square because there's no
Knight coming to C3 and Queen on C2 so
it looks like black has good control of
that diagonal so even if white
eventually gains back that potency for
Fiona I think that block is just
challenging white setup in its entirety
yeah yeah I think once again it's
something we talked about yesterday I
think it's just more difficult these
days to explain these sort of openings
because we've
um
gone so far of the classical path of how
I think if old champions from the past
saw this kind of opening they would be
turning in their graves but I think once
again do we just see the the influence
of these
um modern engines and Ai and all this
stuff so I think it's just for me I
don't work enough with the engines on my
openings to to often comprehend so I
feel very often that I'm just watching
and trying to understand but it is very
difficult I I find with without these
deep insights
um but I agree with you I guess and it
should be comfortable but of course it
is without a doubt it's scary to be
facing what very likely is some World
Championship preparation
exactly and just one quick line I'll
show before we can go to other games as
the niche goes in the think tank is that
instead of A4 I understand that the move
Knight E5 was likely extremely tempting
because there's this Pawn on B7 that's
under attack so we're unleashing that
Catalan bishop and it looks like Anish
just did play the move uh Bishop to C6
if I saw his hand motion correctly and
this move 95 while attacks the B7 Square
black would be able to deal with this
Threat by putting a piece on C6 and that
will triple isolate Black's pawns if
white decides to keep taking things but
this move Bishop C6 Knight C6 Knight C6
already your Pawn on D4 is under attack
and black remains upon ahead if you
triple isolate the pawns now your light
squares are very weak you need this fee
and keto Bishop very often from the
white side because if not this queen
comes at D5 the light squares are
vulnerable and I don't really see any
advantage to speak of for white in fact
I think what could get into big trouble
so that's why Magnus refrained for
playing Knight to E5 and jumping there
too early instead going for this A4 move
and we had the Fallout Bishop C6 Bishop
A3 Rook E8 so Magnus maze intention is
clear he opened up the A3 square and now
the game continues
suggests we come back here in a little
while I'm pretty sure Magnus well is the
familiar with this position we see him
play another fast move Queen C2 uh
hitting the pawn on C4 and maybe I'll
just ask you before we move on Robert
what do you think black should do should
black try and hold on to this pawn and
just give it back
I would probably give it back and moves
that come to mind for me are at some
point A5 just trying to cement that A4
Pawn in place because while for now it's
defended if I can pile up some pieces
say with Knight D7 Knight to B6 I may go
ahead and just win that pawn on A4 at
some point I get it Magnus he's probably
gonna sacrifice it it's not really the
healthiest Pawn to begin with but I do
like the move A5 to stop White Spot from
going there ever and then bring the
Knight to D7 and trying to develop fully
I think that black with accuracy can
hold off any sort of initiative from
white but again with accuracy that's the
key and we're in magnus's preparation
that probably goes much deeper yeah I
will come back here of course in a short
while we'll see if and you can produce
that accuracy you're talking about uh
for now where shall we go do you want to
check in with duboff and kariakin and
see what's go oh
let's go there because there's already
very few pieces left on the board Robert
whoa uh what was move 17 there are no
queens we can let's quickly go through
how we got here uh Knight F3 Knight F6
so we had
a symmetrical position at the start of
symmetrical English and
a quick strike with D5 so what's
interesting is that karjakin went for a
fin Kettle Bishop opening against the
Maestro himself in dubob but he wasn't
going for the Tactical cabinet lines
instead he was trying to isolate dubov's
Pawn on D5 and play a more strategic
positional battle so I think that's a
good choice generally speaking I like
these types of openings from the white
side but a black is well prepared and
duboff prepares Magnus Carlson for World
Championship matches so he if anyone is
very well prepared that you can
neutralize any uh initial problems that
you may face in this opening so I think
it's a good choice for Fiona what about
you yeah I uh I agree I also I think
maybe dubov I wonder how duboff operates
if he thinks after close shave like
yesterday a crazy game I'm happy to to
keep it uh calm today I guess that's
probably not how he operates but I'm
curious yeah how quickly this developed
and
um
and if karyakin can get anything at all
here with the the white pieces
and uh I think you know he called
himself a chicken a year ago he's not
playing chicken this year uh but this D5
Pawn is under attack three different
times so this is a good position for
newer players or people who are just
trying to improve their game to sit and
think about like wait this Pawn on D5
can be captured right that's that's free
at least I think it's free and then you
need to calculate these decisions
because dubov didn't just at the board
decide to play Bishop B6 he has prepared
these variations and karyakin decided to
Castle rather than taking on D5 so these
are these big moments in chess that
often go overlooked because we just
gloss over the openings and ah this is
all normal stuff because we know it but
for newer players or for just advancing
players it's really good to calculate
was Knight takes D5 in option for white
and you look at the evaluation bar right
here like oh wait it's still oh hey
black slightly better but why oh it's
going back to even why is that so it's a
really really X excellent position to
sit and analyze and of course that's our
duty so we'll do it for uh the audience
here but Knight takes D5
of course is an available option to
White in this position so let's talk
about what black can do you can take on
D5 and initiate a queen trade I think
that helps white with the extra material
so what often black does in a position
like this is Play Bishop E6 and just get
rapid development here this Knight can
take a bishop it can take a knight you
can choose but the point is that when we
get to
uh such a position Queen takes D1 King
takes D1 Pawn takes B6 white remains
upon a head but there are tactical
issues this A2 Pawn is pinned to The
Rook so Bishop takes B3 is the threat
there can be a rook on d8 followed by a
knight B4 type of move so all of a
sudden White's King is still in some
danger and there are tactics available
to Black and so white really does not
have an advantage here and the players
know these variations
and I think it also brings us back to
what we were talking about yesterday the
extra Pawn or extra material versus the
initiative and here you can tell I think
one of the things that was difficult for
me to understand
um
and still sometimes this is when you
give up material I think when I was
young and just in my early years of
playing chess I thought if I give
material I have to get something
Concrete in return I have to get some
kind of attack I have to get some kind
of threats well in this case there are
threads as you highlighted along the EA
file but there's just also other
problems there's peace activity
um so I think for anyone looking to
improve their chess I think you're
absolutely right to try and sit down
look at positions like these and try to
understand where does they come
the compensation lie and why is it good
for black in this case to give up that
pawn and why did white not take it
exactly so white decided you know I
don't need those problems I'll just
Castle kingside black played deforce the
pawn lives on attacks the Knight Knight
goes the rim not so dim here because the
attacking a bishop it has a path back
towards the center and then we see
Castle Bishop G5 H6 we see some swapped
pieces and once these pieces get traded
this is the interesting moment uh Fiona
at least from my perspective is black is
down upon
and allows white to
harm the pawn structure by playing Rook
to d8 rather than trading on D4 and it's
one of these moments that show how well
prepared the players are because a move
like Rook d8 is what I would say not a
natural move sure it puts a rook in an
open file it attacks a queen but B6 is
hanging Queen takes F6 G takes F6 just
doesn't look very appealing to to me and
probably to anyone because your pawns
are doubled and isolated over there on
the king side but when you know your
variations when you're backed up by
engine analysis you can make moves like
Rook d8 much more easily and Rook d8
allowed the queen trade and here we are
where
uh in this position after sorry click
the wrong thing after we get here now we
pause and think take stock of what's
happened White's upon ahead has a better
Pawn structure and yet we can see the
Evo Bar says barely better for white
like Fiona it's the new era of Chess
it's with all this engine preparation
absolutely fast though I have to ask
sorry to interrupt there but would you
actually want to play this position as
black because I wouldn't I'm just gonna
be honest with you you would
horrified if you don't know how to play
this position as black but if we look at
it I guess that one of black storms is
what you highlighted uh in the position
we looked at earlier black still has
that control over the a file
uh and I guess the the black Bishop will
come to E6 to try and put some some
pressure along uh that diagonal when
it's maybe not so easy for white to
untangle
um because of of the pressure along the
the light squares but no absolutely at
first sight I would not if I had to play
this upon down I would prefer that at
least my structure on the the king side
was intact rather than being shattered
like that but as you say this is modern
chess and I am sure that we can also
tell from Daniel duboff's time
management he's actually up two minutes
from his starting time so
um I think we can trust him that this
position is fine and that as you say he
has that all of this is backed up by
computer analysis yeah and just to sort
of answer a question that I'm sure is
being asked is why trade queens and yes
weighs up a pawn but couldn't white have
stolen a second pawn and the answer is
after Queen takes B6 it's one of these
positions where white has two extra
pawns but you see the evaluation bar
saying no no Advantage here and there
are a bunch of moves Bishop A6 hitting
E2 B2 is under attack and can be
captured in your future and what often
happens is despite the initial advantage
of material when black starts attacking
things in White's position even a move
like Bishop H3 is quite tempting just
going after the vulnerable light squares
uh black is able to just start stealing
pawns back so you don't regain all the
material on the spot but you create
problems in the positions with the move
like Bishop to A6 and then the queen
eventually taking this Pawn on B2 A2 is
loose E2 is loose and these types of
positions are such that black is okay
being down a couple pawns to begin with
and to further elaborate on your point
Fiona that in the event of this bishop
coming to E6 in the live game
that this Knight wants to stay on B3
because the D2 square is extremely
important you do not want to see that
Rook land on D2 because then it attacks
the all the pawns along the second rank
so I'll move like A3 just like I want to
move my Rook from A1 that will run into
a quick Bishop E6 and then after the
Knight moves Rook to D2 and black seizes
the initiative with an advantage
probably so it's not an easy position
black has so many options coming six
Rook A4 that's double Rooks in the a
file if we need to get active everywhere
so I think that Black's activity makes
up for the material disadvantage
okay so we'll come back to here but it
looks like that Daniel duboff knows
exactly what he's doing I think we could
have a quiet game here but we shall see
um Jordan has Robert shall we check out
one of the the leaders games maybe at
least you didn't call me David so you
have backgrounds for you
uh I like our bird's eye view here we
can just collect our thoughts about all
the games David carwana game a queen
trade is being offered I didn't have a
chance to say this but what I really was
going to say was that I thought that it
would play a pretty quiet peaceful game
against carwana after a very long match
yesterday he did win against Sam
Shanklin he probably was quite tired and
you're playing against Fabiano caruana
who is one of the absolute best players
in the world in the world has been for a
long time so I can understand did it's
decision to just play something a bit
Tamer uh we will probably tune into that
a bit later but it's not the most
exciting game at the moment a problem
Nanda that position against Duda that
position tells me that both players are
trying to win this game they don't want
simple draws they're looking for
fighting interesting chess and then of
course we have mamajarov against
yesapanco where yespengo did not take
the pawn and mom and dad was like come
on just take the g-pawn it still can be
captured two pieces attack it only one
defends it I don't think gessa panko
wants any part of that pawn very
interesting should we maybe start with
pregnant and do that because pregnant
and that their bottom seat of the
tournament but I talked with his coach
Ramesh on the the first day when the
players were being interviewed
and he said you know it's really tough
for players like Prague who barely had
the opportunity to play for for a couple
of years when they were
um I mean Prague had the same rating
pretty much he has today two years ago
when he was only 14. and so I'm really
happy that he is getting the opportunity
to play here and probably his rating
isn't uh completely reflecting the
strength he has because he has of course
been working hard all this time when he
wasn't able to play as much as he would
have liked especially his rapid rating
which I think is like 2 000. it is
unbelievable that these young players
who play like one Rapid or Blitz
tournament when they're like eight years
old they get some rating that's like
1700 they're Grand Masters and 2600 In
classical chess and then you see Lavon
aronian 2770. prognananda two thousand
you're like sorry who is he that's the
same problem Nanda right so it is very
funny when you see and he did really
well in the world rapid actually he was
up near the top so uh now in this game
against Duda we see prognanda focused he
has two nice Central pawns but this is
the nature of the semi tarosh that was
the opening played in this game uh many
of the top players have chosen this line
I know games between kramnik and Wesley
so linear Dominguez plays these
positions I mean you can name pretty
much the who's who of Chess and they
have dabbled with this opening and Fiona
it has the vibe in a way of like a
grunfeld because because of the pawn
structure here on the queen side where
white only has one pawn and black has
two pawns so in certain end games black
is very happy to start using an outside
pass Pawn if you can make one whereas in
the middle game and at this moment
early in the game you see that White's
pawns restrict Black's pieces that's why
we really love having our Pawns in the
center because this bishop on B7 is
limited in scope thanks to pawn E4 the
Knight can't jump to a square like D5
because of these pawns so uh I you like
the center for white but you see black
quickly trying to put pressure on it and
has control over the open C file so what
do you have any experience as either
side in this type of position actually I
was going to ask you because I I don't
have experience in this position from
either side so I was going to to ask you
if you can maybe explain because I think
very often it's uh it's interesting when
I look at a position and I'm not
entirely sure what are the plans I I can
see what you were saying about the White
Center
um and I was curious
um what is the plan for black is it just
to continue putting pressure on the
center points at which point do we want
to start using the pawn majority uh on
the queen side and I also always wonder
how do you decide which pieces do I want
to try and exchange as white and as
black
some great questions and oh gosh is it
time for that break yet because
no but I can answer many of these
questions so you asked really really
good questions and and some of which I
admit that without deep study you won't
know the answer to and you said oh can
these pawns start pushing up the board
at some point you would like to do that
but often with so many pieces still
remaining that it's difficult to push
you know B5 and A5 because as soon as
you push a pawn you create weakened
Square so for example if you play A5
this B5 Square can be controlled by
white and then it's gonna be hard to
play B5 and if you start with B5 maybe
that pawn quickly becomes a Target or
you're going to struggle to play A5 next
so you need to be very careful before
choosing any sort of Pawn push on the
queen side now the idea is oftentimes
it's for white to push this Pawn to D5
and not only is it just gaining space in
the center it often includes a pawn
sacrifice not in every position but it's
actually quite common for white to play
Move Like D5 and Then followed up with
Pawn to E5 so let me just show you what
that looks like I'm going to make an an
actively bad move Rook to A8 why would I
put my rook in the corner it's not a
good decision but I just want to show
you that after D5 Pawn takes D5 there's
some E5 is often played as a response
trying to kick this Knight out the
bishop is hemmed in by its own Pawn
white gains a ton of space the Knight
wants to step in front of this isolated
pawn and you go for an attack so this is
a thematic idea in this type of position
where you try to gain space gain an
initiative and this Rook on E3 it may
look like initially it's just protecting
the pawn that was on e4 but if I can
swing it to G3 I can launch a really
huge attack especially with this Pawn E5
I can push it to E6 use it as a
battering ram and this king is not going
to be very happy on G8 so I did make a
purposely bad move for black playing
Rook to eight but I'm just trying to
show the consequences if black isn't
careful if you think I have everything
under control as we get to the live back
to live position that on there's nothing
going on here no you really need to
watch out for this move D5 if you gave
white a free turn that could actually be
quite devastating for Block to deal with
and I think it's actually really
interesting and I'm very I'm really glad
that you showed us this line because I
think very often
um myself and I'm sure other people as
well look at these kind of positions and
think well material is even everything
seems quite solid on either side but
very often we we underestimate uh or we
failed to see the the dangers at that
line in such positions and and the
opportunities
so definitely I think a very interesting
game this one and as you say I think
both players taking quite an ambitious
approach to Robert now that I've picked
your brains about this position I think
it is time for our first quick break of
the day but don't go anywhere we have
some really really exciting games I
can't wait to get back to remember the
hours as one so don't go anywhere and
we'll see you in just a few minutes
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round two here
at the Tata steel just turn around
2022. Robert did you use our break to
try and calm down after Mama diaro's
three G4
yeah you know honestly I am very happy
with the games that we have we have all
seven on screen for you right now I
couldn't be happier frankly these are
great games they're very exciting some
games are going to Peter out probably
into relatively short draws but you
expect that with great preparation it's
hard to get advantages in a bunch of
games so forbidit against carwana for
kayaking against dubov those games look
like we're heading into territory where
the players can shake hands in the
relative in your future but all the
other games are really exciting
yeah absolutely I think none as exciting
as my media professifenko during the
break I had a quick look at social media
Twitter of course is going absolutely
wild
um I saw that someone brought up I
forgot now who but uh that are 20 years
ago he had played a D4 D5 and then G4 on
move 2 against a certain Matthew kovnett
who is also of course now a Grandmaster
so uh Shakira he has a lot of years of
experience pushing uh pushing those g h
pawns I think he's also lately been
playing a lot of early age four pushes
and so after the the draw from yesterday
which was um
certainly exciting but for him
disappointing he is out for blood today
and Robert well we already mentioned it
before the break but yes the pancreas
did not dare taking the phone on G4
no but he did push mom and Jeff's King
to F1 so Mama Jarvis not going to be
castling he presumably knew that going
into today's game that he would likely
not be able to do that and the G5 Pawn
is under attack a third time so if we
just go back G4 what a decision D5 G5
push Knight D5 and Bishop G2 so this was
already a moment where that pawn could
be captured but I do like yes panko's
choice he's not capturing that pawn
until he feels good and ready because as
soon as you spend another turn with that
Knight you open up this bishop towards
the center all of a sudden white has a
quick initiative uh going for him and
it's clear that yes panko does not want
to allow mom and jar of that kind of
play so sorry Robert I started laughing
because you were talking about taking
that G5 Pawn on his own terms and just
as you were there saying that
I made his move H4 and said too late now
to take that pawn Here Comes sorry no
you are correct to uh you know say that
H4 isn't played so you're not taking
that pawn G5 ever is now his claim right
uh but look at this Fiona I let's be
honest explaining this to like the
newest of new players when they're like
wait my coach told me to develop my
pieces and to Castle my king and you
know to really get everything out there
and control the center and then you see
G4 G5 H4 there's a king on F1
what what do we make of this
I mean I wouldn't know thankfully I'm
not a coach so I don't have to explain
it to any students
um I also think it's very funny we see
now as the panko on camera but a second
ago we were looking at who looks very
very relaxed there he is
um I think this is his home his home
turf I think uh in the late um in the
more recent years of his career he had
to of course he couldn't play the
Firebrand uh attacking chess he's always
been known for but I think this is
really his bread and butter I think at
his core
um in his Junior years Shakira was such
an attacking player and it's an absolute
joy to see him I think for us as chess
fans okay this is hard to explain to uh
to new viewers but it's uh it's so much
fun to see this on the board here at the
highest level
is awesome I mean it really is and you
make a good point that he has come down
in a way uh with his chest he's working
with Alexei drev he's found a more solid
approach but he's getting back to his
roots in this game with his G4 G5 all
that good stuff and actually we can show
certain variations that will justify his
decision to just push his pawns up the
board for example let's say after H4
blocks like all right you're playing
this weird style I'm gonna Castle
because I've been told to Castle and not
only is it a reasonable decision to get
your King on the center the move F6
trying to open up the f file makes
perfect sense even I don't need four
there's a king on F1 let's open up the
board but let's say white goes I don't
know let's say we just trade on D5 and
play the move Knight C3 so I'm already
trying to win a pawn in the center you
can defend or you can go for the exact
type of line I was talking about with F6
I think after F6
you want to open up the f file and I
guess I'm right because the engine's
going up I was going to play the move G6
and say you're not opening up my king
I'm going to open up your king I already
showed I'm willing to sacrifice my
g-pawn on G4 then on G5 now I'm gonna
sacrifice it on G6 and if you take it
I'm going to obliterate your king so
this is the style that Mama Jarvis going
with Fiona and it's really difficult for
yessa panko to meet this over the board
I mean I was just thinking you know when
when absolutely and I think asepenco is
in a difficult situation I think the
position might be fine all that but uh I
was thinking
was already playing this kind of Chess
years before I say panko was even born
yeah so
um yeah I'm very curious to see how he's
going to deal with this certainly very
scary another thought I was having is
here is um seconded by his good friend
and a long time as I read on a teammate
Grandmaster half mamadov
and I was just wondering I wish I could
be a fly on the wall last night or this
morning when they sit down and they go
okay so we're White against yesterday
Funko what are we gonna do
see for Knight F6 C4 E6 what could we
what could we play here
and I really I would love to see what
the thought process is like how they
cooperate to come up if this is shut
just being like look I want to go G4 can
you look this up make it work the best
you can or what the what the process is
I think those conversations can go
something like this now come on be
serious like you know I'm trying to play
good chess no no seriously it's
interesting no you're an idiot we're not
doing that and then you know 30 minutes
later I'm an idiot this is wonderful
let's do it you know it's like it's one
of these things and I I as I've coached
I've worked with the very strong players
that sometimes you just have to come up
with out of the box ideas that at first
you're like no way like this goes
against all my principles everything
I've learned but then when you get a
position like this that's actually quite
justified by the engine but even if it
says you're slightly worse it's really
complex and so that puts the burden on
yessa panko in this case to find the
correct responses and mama jarv is up
nearly 40 minutes on the clock we're on
move seven and yes banko has an hour
left but he's gonna keep eating into his
time trying to figure out do I Castle
here should I start with a move like
I've said six do I really even want to
play F6 when somebody attacks me on the
flank you're supposed to strike in the
center can I play for C5 is it too early
these are difficult questions to answer
and I'm asking them only semi
rhetorically but that's what's going
through yessa panko's mind how do I deal
with this opening that is extremely odd
but now that we're here you start
justifying your opponent's decisions and
now you need to come up with ideas for
yourself absolutely and Robert I'm gonna
go out I'm gonna predict uh Emma media
of win today and I I know you love
prediction so I'm very very curious
about yours
oh uh you know I do have a lot of faith
in Andre he is a fantastic player but
I'm gonna agree with you I think that
body language here says a lot uh yes a
panko looks Mighty uncomfortable and it
is an uncomfortable position to be in
both over the board like the situation
we have after seven moves but just the
notion that wait shot probably has this
prepared another how many moves I mean
am I gonna castle and then eventually
get checkmated of course there's much
more to the game than Mama jar of just
getting whatever he wants but look at
the guy he's so friendly like you know
give the man what he wants and that's a
dub with the white pieces it's so funny
I mean if you just saw the camera
footage of think okay he probably has
some you know a slow Italian game or
some something solid maybe the London on
the word you know the quiet day at the
office but uh no not quite
yeah it's like this is a wild position
and he's acting as if he's been here uh
50 other times but that's mamajara for
you he doesn't need to calculate just
yet and he's very happy with the outcome
of this opening absolutely well I
suggest we come back here a little bit
later I think Andre one of the dangers
really for him in this position is that
he invests too much time as you
mentioned he's already down 40 minutes
on the clock and we only on move on move
seven
so he's going to have to pick it up but
it's just so much easier said than done
because obviously we are not the ones
who are sitting at the board and oh and
very interesting he does cancel kingside
oh I I mean it's of course a move to
consider and it's the one that I played
on the analysis board but
on one hand makes sense you're castling
you're getting your Rook involved on the
other it's like is that playing into
shock's hands because he puts his Pawn
to G5 and H4 he wants to attack you now
if black doesn't touch the F Pawn it's
not going to be easy to attack the King
right you know G6 is a hard move to make
happen with opponent F7 and on H7 if you
ever play H5 finally that G5 Pawn will
be captured but I do like the move
Knight C3 either after taking on D5
first or playing it right away the
reason I didn't play it right away was I
was worried that after the swap of
knights maybe black could even consider
taking this Pawn on C4 and trying to
open up the middle of the board because
there's a king on F1 that King can't
Castle I do want to get after that King
but maybe I shouldn't be so direct so
that's why I like taking on D5 first
then following up with Knight C3 and
trying to start pressuring Black's
Center
yeah I'm very curious I I think your
explanation does make a lot of sense I'm
curious what Chuck is going to play out
be shocked if he was
um if he hadn't looked at this position
when he decided to go for for G4
um so we'll come back here I expected
rather quick move but very very exciting
stuff and shall we check in maybe uh
with Jordan van oh let's go to the
bird's eye view first and see if we've
had any developments elsewhere and I'll
actually let you pick a game yeah I knew
that's where that was going and I was
actually about to compliment you because
I thought going to the bird's eye view
Naturals because our producers and
Graphics team did such a great job with
the layout because then you don't have
to say let's go to this game and then we
go there and it's not that interesting
now we can look in advance and then pick
um the game you mentioned was Jordan Von
forest with Rapport that's still early
it's actually quite an interesting
Dynamic thus far but I have my eyes on
the vidit carwana game and not because
it's the most exciting of positions but
because it might be one of the last
times we can look at that game uh pieces
have been traded no queens challenges
along the uh open D file so let's pull
up that game here and say well Fabiano
has moved very quickly clearly he's in
his preparation and Five Pawns two Rooks
a bishop and a king per side symmetrical
structure more or less and
if you know this looks to me like it
should be a relatively simple draw I
agree and I think uh
lives down a lot to what you were saying
earlier with it played such a long game
yesterday it was a very intense game I
think as Sam defended well and really
took it out of with it so I think that
these things
um not just part of the game he is an
early tournament leader but he is facing
Fabiano caruana the second seed here you
know
um one of the very best players in the
world so I think it makes sense to take
a solid approach as white C also what's
Fabi going to do but if Fabi is happy to
play a solid line it looks to me like
both players here will be happy with the
draw and I would be shocked if this game
went on much longer as long as Fabiana
doesn't go full Bobby Fischer and take
on H2 this game should uh be quite an
easy hold for him and we should actually
go through quickly how he got here
because the game itself had some key
moments it's not like they just
initially wanted to trade all the pieces
and make a draw they got to a position
as we
scroll through here
so this type of position here in the
semi-slaw like it's actually quite
interesting because Black's Bishop on C8
is stuck behind a wall of light Square
pawns and white after casting
is met by this move E5 so black
recognizes that you can't just sit
passively and hope that everything's
going to be okay in this type position
500 decides that I'm not going to do
that instead I'm going to strike in the
center and after C takes D5 C takes D5
you have E4 was played like this is a
hectic position pawns are all staring at
each other in the center four squares
and Fabiano have this worked out to the
point where he realized he didn't need
to be too worried even though White
has a queen on C2 a bishop on D3 lined
up towards the king side over here it's
not a position where he has to fret
because after the trades on e4 he simply
took and played the move H6 so honestly
when I see this position optically it
looks good for white because we are
going to get rid of our isolated Pawn
soon and I have a bishop on e4 and you
have a bishop on C8 but you need to come
up with something concrete otherwise
black is going to finish the development
and then say we've trade off a lot of
material I have no weaknesses you have
no weaknesses it's going to be equal so
I thought the way Fiona that
um probably handled next few moves was
great where he just develops his Knight
to F6 after this position which he looks
even better for white I'm gonna pause
when you look at this position because I
know when I do I'm like white has to be
better right absolutely and then you
pause again and you just see who's
playing here is like oh Fabiano one of
the best prepared players in the world
how much time has he spent to get here
none okay then we'll probably trust him
we do trust him for sure and it's also
one of these positions where if you
haven't been diving too deeply in your
analysis initially the engine could say
like white is quite a deal better and I
could imagine that being the case like
when the engine is thinking back here
and let's say you just okay white has a
slight Edge I'll figure it out because
we can't prepare every single variation
ever so we just sort of go to the all
right looks good is verified let's go
for it but then we keep going and
Fabiano clearly has looked deeply into
this line because Knight F6 attacking
this bishop okay the bishop goes to F5
because he probably didn't want to see
Bishop G4 happen things like that he
plays Bishop F5 and then after Queen A5
he's attacking the bishop forcing a
trade and once the trade happens we can
see that black is in no danger
whatsoever taking with the effort that's
an instructive moment because the a pawn
may need a Defender let's take with the
effort so that that pawn is protected
and then as the game went on Queen D5
again the A7 Pawn is defended because
the a rook is still here and black took
the effort so these little moments are
if we're not prepared let's say we
actually played this game without any
previous knowledge we might just take
with the a rook an instinct we wouldn't
even think about it we'll take with the
a rook but it was important for him to
take with the F Rook now he plays Queen
D5 uh sure
white can take on F6 and hurt Black's
King side but black can do the same over
here on the queen side and so the game
just now
I'm sorry Robert to interrupt you but I
was hearing some commotion nearby which
is the player's entrance and exit so
we've had our first result of the day if
we pull up the bird's eye view at the
game between Sergey kariakin and Daniel
duboff I think unsurprisingly uh has
ended in a draw and well no need to go
there on camera because we just heard
the players
um leave the building so maybe we can
quickly go back there if you want and
see how that game ended
sure uh no surprises as you said the
game was pretty good preparation by
dubov in particular he was where we left
off and the game continued Rook to D1
and that's sort of an admission that I'm
not going to be able to win this game
because after Rook D1 Rook D1 Rook takes
A2 would be a huge blunder Rook d8 check
will scoop up this bishop on C8 but
Bishop E6 now the pawn can't go to A3
because the Knight on B3 is under attack
and now after Knight to C1 trying to
protect the pawn black still takes it
this is not a Fisher Bishop after B3 the
bishop can actually sneak to B1 or The
Rook can come to A3 to attack the pawn
but karakin said ah let's just do this
thing let's make the draw King G7
protecting this Pawn on F6 C6 will fall
so will B2 and then the game is just a
drop because
at this point it is Rook 4 Rook 4 and
yes black has a pass Pawn but these
players know Rook end games inside and
out there's no way to win this position
especially with shattered Pawns of the
king side absolutely so no additional
drama here today in the Dual karyakan
Saga a peaceful draw between the two
players and
um well let's bring back the bird's eye
view again Robert and uh let's see what
updates do you see where would you like
to go next
well we should definitely go to one of
the games we haven't looked at yet and
that is Shanklin and against grendelius
and report against van Forest uh the
other games we've at least taken some
look at and I mean honestly those games
are still very tense no as a single
piece been traded in either game
no no incredible shall we start with uh
van ferries who is one of our early door
leaders and Sean Clan grandel is also an
interesting Clash of course between two
players who lost their respective games
yesterday so it's also always
interesting how much risk they are
willing to take
no that's very true and here we have Von
forest with the black pieces against
Rapport and honestly this looks too
normal to be a report position right I'm
used to uh very hard playing all sorts
of different openings and novelties and
just uh kind of with a flare and here's
like wait this is just solid why is he
doing that maybe it's because he lost
yesterday but either way we're only on
move 10 Fiona and the players have been
thinking quite a bit and when you look
at this position
zero pieces have been traded now what's
your first read of the situation
well I I see um that both players well
black has already gotten the king into
safety white uh still has to decide what
he wants to do with the Bishop from F1
is that going to go either to E2 or D3
or might we see the bishop jankato
um I see that white has two kind of
ponds in the in the centers on V4 and C4
but black has already thrown one piece
into the opponent Camp the Knight has
made its way to e for
um so yeah those are the things I see I
always find it sort of hard to judge
um who do I like better I think if
Jordan follows this up with some F5 some
pushes some Pawn pushers then you might
get to convince me that I like black
better but for now as always I'm kind of
curious as your insights and what the
idea is for for both sides are here
you know if you know we've known each
other for a long time now and I'm
getting the sense that you like
attacking chess yes something leaves how
do you get that idea
oh you're like oh F5 then I'll take
black there and you know I agree if
white isn't careful because White's King
is still in the center then black can
really start seizing the initiative and
going for an attack and the reason why
is how this opening went this Knight on
F3 it actually didn't just go Knight G1
to F3 it went Knight H4 and then it
returned to F3 so white has spent a
bunch of moves with this one piece and
black on the other hand when Bishop F5
and then Bishop back to E6 once that
Bishop was attacked so we can actually
very quickly
go through the opening here that the
bishop came out to F5 and then report
when Knight to H4 so he attacking the
bishop sending it back to E6 and then
played E3 but something that's
interesting
is that after this sequence here
which is all very normal moves by both
sides that I would think that you wanted
to kick this bishop away so you could
play Bishop D3 yourself now Bishop D3
isn't that appealing when black has this
Pawn structure here with the finchetto
because you're staring into a wall of
Pawns but then why did you go Knight H4
that's a little unclear to me and after
Rook C1 Knight E4
you can't take on e4 but look at your
knight on H4 I don't think you're very
happy because your night's about to be
trapped by the move G5 your King's still
in the centers or queen A5 check you
have to watch out for that at any moment
the C5 is on the docket thanks to the
open Bishop that's not a right diagonal
that is though the bishop on G7 so black
is clearly better in a situation like
this which is why instead he returned
Knight to F3 but as we see this position
like the bishop
went to F5 back to E6 that Knight went
to H4 back to F3 but doesn't really feel
to me at least Fiona that white has Dean
from it and I would start with move
Queen A5 for black probably yeah I I
would agree with you
um and I guess what you're saying is
this was an opening success for Jordan
with the the black pieces who seems to
maybe have equalized already here
yeah and there have been zero trades so
really what happens from now will be
consequences Roberts just as you said it
Queen A5 is on the void
it's a hard move not to play because
you're attacking a pawn and A2 while
pinning this Knight on D2 and with this
Knight on e4 there are no Bishop C3
moves which would be a very good
response if this Knight were not here so
the pin exists the pawn is under attack
and will white spend another turn
pushing a pawn instead of you know
making his way towards castling by
playing A3 where eventually he could
play B4 but I think that black has zero
to worry about everything is protected
and yeah it's looking solid I said maybe
you're an equalizer already maybe
already more than equalized but uh yeah
you're then after his win from yesterday
uh certainly got a nice position out of
the opening here today we are gonna go
for a quick break now during the break
you will see our producer Bigfoot
challenge checking in with the
Challenger is telling you what's
happened uh in that group yesterday and
we'll be back in just a few minutes it
so we'll see you then
[Music]
yes welcome everyone let's just check up
with the challengers each day next to
the Masters will also have Challenger
games ongoing and every day we're going
to look at them have a little bit of a
checkup and see how they are doing and
today we're having a look round one it
was Aaron Lamy against uh beerbu and uh
everybody everyone let me is a
well-known Dodge Grandmaster also's beer
they're both trying to fight hard and
violently to get to the top place and we
all know the saying nobody notices a
common housefly until it ruins a good
bowl of soup and these try are trying to
get it going and I picked up this game
it's very interesting uh to say the
least they're both very solid very
active you see double Pawn here on B3
and V2 and after the move C5 the evil
bar is shooting up because after a
simple uh capture here
and we go back we actually have Rook a
free we're going to pin down on that A7
Pawn Rook B8 Rook A1 and we're actually
gonna go in for that pawn H6 is a quick
quiet move to make sure we don't get any
hassle on the king side and after we get
some traits here
and we go back Knight to D2 and we're
solid we defend our pawn it is a double
bond so The Rook does have some left
over but we see the evaluation it's plus
one so that would be a great move but
white
had a quick idea about this pin on a C8
and a D7 file with this bishop right
here
so what happened in the game
D5 they traded off
and after all that we have a bishop to
G4 hitting that Bishop The Rook of D7
and The Rook on C8 and black said that's
fine
because right after here Bishop E6 I'm
going to be incredibly solid these pawns
are going to swing in here there's no
entryway there's going to be a very weak
deforce going to play at night I'm going
to play my Bishop I'm going to dominate
you right here this is absolute perfect
play he's a pawn uh he also has an extra
Pawn for the exchange so black is
actually very soft they also see diesel
bar is it real with me it's a 0.0 now
some moves were played
and we actually have
right here Bishop takes D4
and knights D6 and we can already see
here this bishop is an absolute Beast an
absolute monster it cuts off the King
right here there's a beautiful
synchronization here on the king side uh
four black and they're pushing white
doesn't really have any entryways so
black is in a very good position
however we had an over the board Mouse
slip as it seems because of the move
a five now A5 makes it that the Knight
goes to B5 this bishop gets traded off
uh which is the strongest piece on the
board this Pawn will fall afterwards and
this is what happens now the idea
presumably after A5 is that let's say
Rook A1 hitting that A7 pump we saw the
trick earlier try and double up with the
Rooks going for that pawn Aaron probably
thought well might as well play A5 solid
by position completely missing Knight B5
unfortunately
a move that would have been interesting
and would have been better is actually
the move Bishop to h8 now a quick
question why not Bishop 2g7 uh that's
purely because of this Knight to E8 and
again you're gonna trade off The Rook
for that Bishop which is not something
that we would like in this position so
bishop h8 and after Knight to B5 that is
a bishop that cannot go to B5 I have
tried it just has come software is not
letting me Rook to B7 I'm gonna kick out
that night at some point we have a very
nice idea of looking at B2 so this Rook
is kind of stuck we're going to start
marching these pawns down on the king
side and we have a perfectly fine
position however it did not pan out
because of A5 it was traded off
this Palm will fall the king's coming in
and actually it was a very nice ending
here at the end of the bishop H3
we went back to Rook
all the way to the back rank is trying
to go for the Checkmate now let's see
how that plays out the King goes to G4
saw the Checkmate and thought well I'm
just gonna head out and this Pawn start
pushing and after a few checks air move
G6 this is where white resigns because
it's impossible to stop this Checkmate
from coming if you think like well I'm
just going to run up if you're going to
give a check
it's going to be annoying but at least
right now I'm safe that's not going to
happen because I will chase you down all
the way after King H6 I'm gonna promote
and again
there's this Checkmate there's nothing
you can do about it if you think well
I'm going to give a quick check trying
to make life a little bit uneasy for you
that's not gonna happen because the king
is safe and Checkmate will be delivered
on the next move a fantastic move
fantastic game absolutely fantastic game
uh by Jonas he's been playing uh
fantastic in that book I said fantastic
a lot of times because it was a
fantastic game uh Aaron's going to try
to be the back we have three winners in
the first round and uh we'll be back
soon to see who won uh who's gonna get
it to the Masters
foreign
[Music]
is coming this June watch all the top
players you see on screen in front of
you plus two more to be decided by the
fide Grand Prix so the candidates are in
June you chester.com TV will you'll be
able to join exclusive footage of the
playing Hall and expert commentary on
every move and you'll also be able to
enjoy coverage of the feed 8 Grand Prix
the leg one begins February 3rd it will
include players like vidit Gujarati
Hikaru Nakamura and many more stars in
The Chess World as they Vibe for those
last two spots in the candidates Fiona I
know we're in the middle of Tata steel
we just started but I'm really excited
for those other events as well I'm super
excited of course I love being here at
Tata steel oh uh I got sidetracked there
by a second there are appearing I think
we had called it a visit and Karana
looked very very equal last time we were
there it makes a lot of sense and so two
draws here so far between videot and
Karana and kariakin and dubov but yeah
absolutely so excited for the the
candidates tournament figure out who's
gonna be the next challenge I think
everyone is so excited to see uh alireza
um playing his first candidates and as
you said who is going to fill in those
last two spots is it gonna be someone
who's here or not we shall find out
throughout February
and March but for now back to the bird's
eye view
and Robert what do you make of the
development
well there are many uh two games in the
books we'd know about that as you just
mentioned and I mean the game between
Shanklin and grendelius we haven't
actually looked at it yet so maybe
that's where we should start uh because
Sam Shanklin and Niels Grand dealers
both lost their games yesterday and
they're in a battle right now they are
not playing a peaceful game it didn't
have a single trade for a long time but
I'll move 15 here Fiona the move F5 was
just played so first glance would you
prefer to have the black side of this
position yes sorry absolutely you know
me well I see a Pawn on E5 especially if
Paul on F5
um and I like it I was thinking actually
and you probably can confirm this but
the two players if I'm not mistaken were
both part of Team Carlson in 2016.
foreignly uh well but I think both of
them such fighting players so I'm not
surprised that we have a battle on our
hands here today
and if you're a Sam Shanklin after
yesterday's defeat you look at this pair
and you have the white pieces that's the
first bit of good news and you're
playing someone lower rated than you are
in the tournament most players in the
field over 2700 Niels grandiose
incredibly strong last year actually was
leading the tournament early but he is
one of the lower rated players in the
field so if you just think about
tournament strategy for Sam Shanklin
it's probably a game he feels like he'd
really like to get as there are no easy
customers period but as far as the
pairings go this is I guess one of the
quote-unquote better ones but by the
position Fiona I also like this for
black because I see a rook on B7 and
typically we don't like fee and Kettle
Brooks but I see that future that Rook
is coming over to F7 especially if a
knight comes to D5 for white and we
trade Knights over to the king side that
Rook goes and I'm feeling really good as
you mentioned the pawns on E5 and F5
black just has more space and more
advanced Pawns yeah I really like this
for black I also think that Bishop on G7
for now is looking down at the
undefended night on C3 of course for the
moment there's still a couple of black
pieces in the way
um but no I really like this and to me
it's another reason I like this for
black it's not immediately clear to me
how white wants to proceed what White's
plan is
I think with the Knight on C3 and E3 a
knight's coming to D5 that feels kind of
necessary not just desired because black
might have F4 F3 type of ideas if you're
not careful I mean if the first move
will attack the Knight the second move
might shatter White's Pawn structure and
open up the king and the F3 square is a
light square there's no light Square
Bishop that Bishop on G2 was traded for
Bishop on B7 and that means that moves
like F4 F3 are actually even more
dangerous especially if this queen can
join the party on the light squares what
do you make of of thumbs
um body language here we see him
uh very focused just leaning back there
now I don't know some too well I I guess
you know him a lot better can you read
anything into him
I think that body language is still from
yesterday's game I
was like a joke right but I I some
players are really good at just washing
away the past and be like today's new
game I have to focus some players are a
bit more emotional and also you know
results can rattle them and Sam is a
fantastic player extremely well prepared
I don't think he gets enough credit for
how strong he is because people often
just chalk it up to oh he prepares
really hard and that's meant as
something a bit like derogatory but also
hard work is a skill and he has really
uh perfected that skill and he did just
by the move Knight to D5 so I think that
he's not happy about his position right
now and he shouldn't be because he's
objective he's playing game of chess but
I do think that yesterday's results is
probably still lingering in the back of
his mind and as he did just play the
move Knight to D5 he justified his setup
with Pawn night night that square is
going to be under a White's control and
if we think about what trades we want
you've asked this question before and we
should all always ask ourselves this
question ideally this night goes away
for this bishop and then we trade Knight
so just to
force that bear with me I know it's a
bad move I just want to show you
everybody that if Knight B3 is played
and then we get this trade here this is
what white would love to see the Knight
on D5 it gets a bishop that can never
attack it because that White Knight has
an outpost and that Bishop is staring
into just the thin air not attacking
anything so this is the ideal transition
that Shanklin wants to go for and of
course Niels is not going to oblige as
so how do you
um as black
well of course uh I guess you can still
take on D5 but then how do you proceed
uh after that or do you even not want to
take on D5 at all
I guess you you probably will take on D5
just because at this point Bishop G5
looks like an annoying threat and I'd
rather just get rid of that thread
altogether and in the event of a trade
here and in fact Niels has just played
Knight 65 this Rook can swing to F7 and
the threat is stronger than the
execution they say F4 may be a good move
at some point but you don't want to rush
that decision because as soon as you
play F4 we talked about the D5 squares
and outpost then E4 is hard for black to
cover in addition to D5 in addition to
G4 so F4 is a very committal choice and
maybe black won't split H5 H4 Go full
Alpha zero let's push that H component
the board go for an attack I don't see
why not and I really don't have plans to
speak up for white one is to eventually
try to Chisel at the queen side with A4
A5 but Black's initiative looks really
powerful here I would certainly take
Neil's position yeah Nils is a dynamic
player so I think he will be very happy
with what he is gotten here Sam is
hesitating but he has just recaptured
with the Knight on D5 and I like your
suggestion a lot of Rook F7 but we will
come back here and see what Nils decides
he is currently away from the board so a
good opportunity for us to to jump
around maybe go back to Magnus Carlson
and Anish giri who we haven't seen in a
little while
we'll definitely go right there because
that game is actually heating up a bit
and the move Knight B6 we were talking
earlier about what Black's idea was and
he put us on A6 rather than A5 so just
to go to that moment Bishop C6 Bishop A3
Queen C2 is where we left off and Anisha
I'll continue my development I'm not
scared Knight to D7
Rook to C1 was played which is such an
interesting choice as you don't need the
Rook there to attack the pawn but he's
forcing anisha's hand in a way he's like
make your intentions clear to me if you
play Knight B6 trying to defend the pawn
then I play A5 and kick your knight out
of here so if you play A5 now I know for
certain you're putting your Pawn in A5
and maybe that is what Magnus wanted but
instead Anish put A6 because now black
is ready to play B5 and defend that pawn
and that's why Magnus finally takes
Anish plays Knight to B6 and now there
is a problem with a fork and queen C3
have the pawn I don't care about it says
Magnus it's doubled it's isolated you
can have that one but look at the center
that's what often these games come down
to Robert I'll have to ask you once
again because I think it's again a move
that's kind of hard to understand I
understand you give up the pawn on A4
you had no choice but why would you put
the queen on a square where it's gonna
be under attack if the Knight takes
I wish you didn't ask me that question
um it's a really good one the choice of
where to move the queen right we have C5
we I'll just put the sort of the squares
that you can go to all of these like how
do you choose uh between these squares
it looks like Wordle I'm playing the new
game that everyone's obsessed with uh
and trying to figure out what's the
correct order of things and it's not
easy uh queen of B4 or queen of B3 have
Merit in the sense that if I just show
Knight takes A4 doesn't work because a
rook takes C6 that would be a huge
blunder white Scoops off two minor
pieces for the rook and it's just
completely winning as you see the eval
bark goes Sky High so Queen to keeping
in touch with A4 while opening the C
file will
prevent black from taking on A4 with the
Knight but if you play Queen B3 then the
bishop can take with the tempo if you
play Queen B4 a knight can come in D5 or
a pawn can come to A5 with Tempo and
then A4 will fall anyway so what Magnus
does here with Queen C3
is he's inviting Knight takes A4 with
Tempo that seems like the absolute most
obvious move ever and when I'm starting
to wonder Fiona and this is a bit deep
is he about to sacrifice an exchange is
Knight takes A4 Queen B3 now Rook takes
C6 is the threat I mentioned it just
before and if Knight Returns the B6 is
there something to be said for an
exchange sacrifice on C6 and a knight to
E5 taking this Pawn or Rook to C1 taking
this Pawn claiming that the minor pieces
are actually just as good as the Rook
because the Rooks don't have too many
squares to work with right now I see the
evaluation bar saying something these
evaluation bars typically on a
relatively low depth especially compared
to what the top gems use their neural
Nets and leaving the engines on not just
you know for a few minutes but all night
to verify the lines I could see
something like this happening and Magnus
going for it it is he didn't go for
something like this against Pharmacy in
that very topsy-turvy game too
absolutely I mean I I like the look of
this this is one a very nice Bishop here
for white especially of course the
bishop on G2 looking down the light
square is towards A8 and while you're
explaining all this I was looking a
little bit at a niche on the on the
camera who looks somewhat perplexed like
he keeps doing this uh faces and he's
just about to take the pawn only for I
guess it will be with the Knight
Knight takes A4 was played and uh I
actually I I like your idea I'm very
curious if Magnus is going to go for
that I guess at this point if Magnus
wants to exchange uh wants to give up
the exchange there is nothing a niche
can do about it or am I wrong
no you're you're right that he can't
there I don't think there's anything he
can do about it but maybe anisha's
calculated that said that's fine for me
I'm not too worried and those kind of
exchange sacrifices aren't as much about
the moment like in that moment black may
actually be slightly better but the
moves seem more difficult to play for
black and that can lead to a nagging
positional bind that white can have and
that's where the compensation is and
Magnus gets back to the board I'll be
curious to see how quickly he plays
another idea he can go for is like Queen
C2 rookie one Pawn E4 it feels slower
but maybe he's able to get away with
that because typically the way Queen C2
is met is with a move like Bishop E4 you
can't do that initially because the
Knight is hanging on A4 and you can't do
it after even retreating the Knight
because then C7 is loose so I could see
him retreating Queen C2 I'm now very
intrigued by The Exchange sacrifice and
I'm sure Magnus is as well and he's
making his move quickly I think it's
Queen B3 yeah Queen B3 you know Robert
I'm curious about your thoughts on this
I have a feeling it it's not completely
out of the out of the question that
Magnus could have had this position uh
on the board before we know how
extensively he has prepared for the
world champion that the Catalan was a
part of that so do you think there's a
chance that Magnus uh even if he hadn't
didn't have it on the board this morning
that he has seen this position before
it's a great question because we look at
the clocks Magnus has spent over 20
minutes at this point and well over 20
minutes if you include increment so that
may indicate to some that he's not in
his preparation he's spending time he's
calculating over the board but Fabiano
gave great insight into this during the
World Championship when he was saying
that I wouldn't be surprised if this is
still preparation you're just
remembering your lines because you don't
want to mix up one variation for another
where in one variation uh you know you
should push this doubled a pawn to A4
but another you shouldn't so like these
little things have the biggest
consequences at this high level so to
answer your question I think he could be
still in preparation I I can't say with
any certainty but giving up a pawn in
this manner
if he does go over takes C6 then I will
really believe that he is within his
preparation and as you said it's no
opening he was playing during the World
Championship absolutely I think this the
last couple of moves the speed with
which he he went for this queen C3 Queen
B3
um of course he could have come up with
it over the board and calculated a lot
beforehand but
um if I was a Anish giri I would start
getting a little bit worried right now
yes because Anisha is looking oh as Rook
takes C6 about to happen and if it is
and I'm afraid of it how can I stop it
and I'm not really seeing easy ways a
move like Queen to D5 looks pretty
awkward to my eyes and perhaps doesn't
even stop the sacrifice but like you're
walking into a diagonal where there's a
bishop so if that Knight moves out the
way that could be some trouble
eventually so I yeah I don't really know
if a niche can get away with the move uh
Queen to D5 because you know just going
forward with this exchange sacrifice if
you take on B3 I take with the pawn and
then your Knight's still under attack so
I get two pieces for the rook and if you
take the Rook then Knight E5 I'm going
for your B7 pawn queen B5 looks
necessary and it's a mess and that's a
queen B5 let's say I even play Queen C2
drop back here Knight's awkward Rook B1
happening B7 is loose C7 is loose and
this just from an energetic standpoint
looks so nice for white
absolutely and I I wouldn't be surprised
if something like this happens I think
an ish also is running risk here on the
the clerk he is currently down half an
hour but this looks like the kind of
position where he's going to be needing
to invest a lot more time than Magnus
who seems very at home these days in
these positions where he gives up some
material gets the initiative gets very
active piece play
um so yeah Anish well you you called it
a couple of hours ago Robert I think
accuracy today plenty more accuracy will
be needed for Manish we'll come back
here shall we bring back the bird's view
again
and see what's been happening elsewhere
sure and we know we had two draws
already two very tame games between did
it and carwana and then also kariakin
and dubov that doesn't mean that you
shouldn't analyze those games because we
take for granted some key Moments by
just pressing the next Arrow and not
actually analyzing the games themselves
but as we look at the games that remain
in prognan Duggan's Duda we see some
pair Bishops have been traded but we
still have the dynamic we talked about
earlier with the E4 and D4 pawns for
white so an extra Pawn the center but an
extra Queen Side Pawn for black and that
Dynamic will remain and will be very
important as the game continues I do
like pragnada's position for the moment
at least and report and then Forest
they're moving slowly in terms of move
number but that position is heating up
fast
Fiona Mama jar of and yes panko that
one's slowing down though
yeah absolutely I mean not too many
moves uh have happened after castles it
looks like maybe we can quickly go there
and then go to to pragnananda
because only a couple of moves have been
played and I think today Robert you know
me well I'm a fan of a couple of things
I love my attacking chess and I love me
some good at time travel as a as a chess
fan and I think today there's a lot of a
lot of games where we've only played
quite few moves and maybe it's a good
moment to very quickly remind our
viewers of what the format here is what
the time control is so it is a 14 player
single round robin and the time control
it is a long one 100 minutes for the
first 40 moves 50 minutes for the next
20 and then an additional 15 minutes uh
on move 60 with a 30 second increment
from move one but that doesn't mean the
players are not gonna get uh in time
travel and I I think today get ready for
that that fourth hour of play because I
think there's going to be a lot of
players in time travel today most likely
including these two
yes because we're only on move eight
that was the move that was just played
and now mama jarov is the one sitting
and thinking so yessa panko he was
surprised by the opening but now that
we're here
he You could argue that he won the
opening battle he's not in any danger in
terms of King safety uh his position
looks very solid and so how do we you
know justify all this craziness from
Mama jarv I'm almost wondering and look
he's already played many moves that go
against principles like can he just take
this and then play Knight C3 and go for
the pawn it's greedy chess it's saying
that I'm not gonna go Checkmate you I've
moved my king I've already moved my
pawns up the board instead of developing
but can he actually take this Knight and
after Pawn takes E4 give up his fee and
kettled Bishop and all these light
squares and then just play a move like
Knight C3 going right after the pawn
it's risky
but I could see this being a good try
for Mama jarv especially considering
that he's not going to get that attack
that he wanted so Fiona Bishop Harris we
know and we love but what do you think
about trying to go for the spawning for
yeah the the problem I see with this
position of course I would prefer not to
give up the bishop pair but it's it's
not so clear to me if I don't take on e4
uh what do I proceed if we go go back
maybe for a second to the to the current
position on the board I don't know if
what you said earlier is still an option
to take on D5 and play Knight C3 but it
is starting to to feel a little bit
slower as as black is consolidating his
position
with every move and I to be honest I'm
I'm very surprised Jackie I've spent 16
minutes on Knight H3 and now he's once
again deep and fought and I I'm curious
um what could have surprised him here
out of the moves that black played like
surely he must have looked at at Castle
so um yeah I'm very curious what's going
on here in this battle but I agree with
you that uh I know it was only a couple
of moves ago that I called the white
wind but I think asapanko has handled
himself when and I I think Shakir will
need to show us something here quite
soon
yeah you're right because if he prepared
this line I mean castling was a pretty
normal option from yessa panko yes if it
goes to nothing out of the ordinary so
to think for such a long time when
playing Knight H3 it may mean that Mom
and yours out of his preparation and
that's not a good sign for him because
if he can't make the situation a bit
clearer his King is way worse off and at
some point F6 might be an idea and even
if not for F6 black will just continue
developing so it looks like a move has
in fact just been played in Queen C2 was
that and I see the eval bar starting to
hover in Black's favor here but we can
tell what Mama jar is up to he is going
after this Knight I would if I were yes
mango think about retreating the Knight
to D6 putting immediate pressure on the
C4 pawn and then Knight can go to a
square like F5 and the attack D4 I just
feel like white is underdeveloped and I
think the black's better
yeah I'm
I tend to agree with you I still think
that
um that there is also a psychological
aspect here of playing this position
over the world against who is so well
known for his attacking chess for his
uncompromising chess so I still think
the position isn't
completely comfortable but I agree with
you that Andre despite his young age
already a very experienced player we
have seen last year he's not afraid of
anyone he can take down the world
champion he can take down the rest in
the world and he doesn't look too
stressed and he shouldn't I just to
quickly show what this looks like Knight
D6 attacks a pawn if you say oh I'm
going to
push my Pawn here then Knight F5 attacks
D4 and H4 like you have to be very
careful as white because your whole
position can fall apart look at the eval
we made two pretty normal looking moves
and it's saying that black is just
crushing so I would not like to be in
his position for Mama jar of anymore
Knight D6 and if the pawn takes on D5
this Pawn takes back and now my Bishop
is open I can go to F5 this e file is
blacks for the taking and there's just
no attack so I'm I'm really liking yes
Banko's chances right now oh and a big
thank you we don't usually do shout outs
uh on stream but a big shout out to
Daniel wrench who has just subscribed
for 50 months and nice and round
anniversary Danny good to have you here
with us thank you for subscribing and
actually
sorry the real question is why was he
not already subscribed
[Laughter]
very true
um but no welcome welcome Danny and
actually we're gonna go on a quick break
soon but I just wanted to ask you one
last question about this uh game Robert
it is about that move Knight H3 because
I feel like that was the turning point
we left off after cancels we I kind of
like white and we come back Knight H3
has been played and we sort of
um changed on once I'm just curious what
do you think is the idea behind Knight
H3
I
the Knight can go to F4 so Knight F3
would seem like a more natural
developing square but you want to think
about the prospects of your pieces so I
do think that with Knight H3 baby had
some ideas of going to F4 and that puts
pressure on D5 maybe then I can go to H5
later or just try to initiate an attack
but no I
I don't know Knight H3 is not the first
move that I would have considered uh but
even after Knight H3 after C6 I think
that if you're getting into a position
like this at some point you need to
create some problems for black but yeah
I'm with you Fiona the move Knight H3
feels quite obscure and it's not a move
that I would have chosen well time will
tell what's going to happen here at the
moment yeah panko is the one thinking
after Queen C2 let's take a quick look
at the bird's eye view before going on a
break
um so one more time to remind the two
games have ended in draws vidded against
Karana and kariakin against uh dubov but
plenty of action remains on the
remaining birds and Robert I guess
you're particularly curious maybe about
the next move in Carlson Geary
I'm very interested to see if Magnus
picks up that Rook takes the bishop on
C6 because then we're in for a slug Fest
and I'm also you know when we get back
I'm looking forward to these prognananda
game as well things have changed looks
like those Rooks in the D file behind
the D4 Pawn that is a past Pawn right
that pawn can push up the board I'm
liking prognano's position at this point
but there's still so much chess left you
know you are absolutely right absolutely
Prague mananda looks like a great start
to the tournament for him so far we will
check back in with him and all the other
games after a short break so don't go
anywhere and we'll be back in just a few
minutes
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to round two here at the
Tata steel chess tournament and Robert
we're just going to dive straight back
into the world champions game Magnus
Carlson who is still thinking after
Anish giri's last move Queen to D5
yeah I mean it's a critical moment in
this game we were looking at Rook take
C6 as a potential exchange sacrifice you
know Magnus is looking at that but
perhaps we're tunneling right that's
such an attractive move because it's
tactical it makes black have to work to
find a way to keep everything together
but there must be other options that
he's considering and I was thinking
about it during our break just now
a retreating move it's an odd looking
move but I was wondering what happens in
the event of Knight to E1 so Jordan Von
Forest he inspired me with from his
Knight D1 yesterday sometimes retreating
moves are the best moves and it makes
sure the bishop is defended because at
night move that doesn't defend the
bishop results in Checkmate but my main
idea is that they're 91 if you trade
Queens if you're quick to do that and I
take back on B3 now your Knight's under
attack and your Bishop's under attack
and behind the bishop is a hanging Pawn
so I'm just trying to be quite forceful
if you move your knight initially I take
on C6 twice I have a much better Pawn
structure and ending if you take on G2 I
can I don't even know how I should take
back but either piece I take back with
your knight has to move and then Rook
takes C7 lens on the board I'm active I
equalize the material and I have a
bishop first a knight
um imbalance so that's what I'm looking
for From magnus's perspective and it
looks really interesting to make this
night Retreat I think it's a really
interesting move Knight E1 and as you
said I think it's a move that very often
we just don't have on our radar at all
because I I think someone well many wise
people have said this before that
retreating moves in chess often the most
difficult moves and
to come up with in general we always
look we want to go forward so taking a
piece back is a move that's often hard
to see and especially here when there's
so many attractive Alternatives
um but then as you say when you look
into the into the move closer I you have
convinced me Robert I have to say it
because it's also not clear if a niche
doesn't in this position take on B3 then
what else then there are other problems
right this C6 situation is still an
issue I mean it looks really risky but
putting yourself into a pin with Knight
E4 I say it with no confidence but
the eval bar didn't react so 94 I guess
with this setup here everything is
defending this Knight and I mean what a
weird position terrifying
it looks like it looks like it should
not work and even a movie Rook takes C6
has to be considered and actually rip66
looks really interesting
and why does this not just this Knight
is now loose this Knight is under attack
how in the world can black just be okay
here
I'm very very confused
I mean it looks extremely good I I give
Queen takes here
maybe this position after white gets the
two pieces uh for the Rook E2 does hang
so it's it's two pawns and a rook for
two minor pieces in which case now I can
see why the engines is the black is
doing just fine but that's such a scary
position to be in from the start like
you know right here this Knight is loose
this Knight is pinned and everything
seems to be wobbly here for black and
yet of course it's just fine I mean it's
so tough because Magnus very lightly at
some point he hasn't been thinking for a
while here very likely he has considered
Knight E1 probably also considered work
C6 but it's so tough because after 91 if
you then have to figure out all the
intricacies of Knight E4
um yeah I'm very very curious to see
what the world champion decides on here
and it's actually Robert I think the
first moment in this game where he's
really spending some time
yeah and I mean I'm so now folks in 91
the Knight H4 should also be mentioned
as doing the same thing protecting the
bishop opening up the bishop to the
queen uh but both are options here and
Magnus he understands that this moment
is critical so people ask this question
often Fiona and I really don't have a
great answer because I do think it's
dependent on each and every game but
they ask how do you know when a moment
is critical how do you know when it's a
moment that you should spend time on and
here actually is a good illustration of
that because there's uh material
sacrifice when White's already down upon
but you can play this with Rook takes C6
which we have looked at earlier and we
can continue to look at and there are
different moves like Queen retreating
somewhere or Knight to E1 or Knight to
H4 they're like five different options
that all look pretty reasonable some of
which include some pretty big material
sacrifices absolutely and I think that
very often uh my understanding is when
is a critical moment why it's so
important to identify these moments is
because that's when you want to invest
at the time and really buckle down
double check and that's where you want
to to invest
um that clock time and I think very
often those are moments which are going
to change the character of the position
and here well The Exchange sacrifice for
sure would change their character but
yeah it's really a pivotal moment and um
magnus's next move is going to to decide
in which direction this game is going to
proceed
and there's also something to note that
Rook tasty six is a bit more forcing
than say a knight H4 91 because we can
sense the next let's say five moves like
Rook C6 Queen has to take on C6 to keep
the Knight defended as we mentioned if
Queen takes B3 politics B3 now your
knight is lost so you take a rook but I
get two minor pieces with this monster
Bishop pair it's gonna be winning for
white so you have to go Queen C6 95. now
your Queen's under attack twice and you
need to protect the Knight Queen to B5
now Queen C2 looks really good keeping
up the pressure threatening Rook B1
trying to remove the queen as a Defender
from the Knight and then let's say the
Knight goes to B6 now because Bishop
takes B7 to work rubber to interrupt you
yeah we've had a move and I think it is
Rook take C6
oh well then perfect he played Rook
takes C6 great camera work by the way
look at that Rook it's not going to be
there very long but Rook takes C6 was
played and Nisha is about to recapture
that Rook was Queen uh there's really no
other move so he's going to do just that
but I love the damage yeah no it's
awesome and he hasn't moved yet so he he
might be surprised by Rook takes C6 and
Anish is now gonna have to work through
all these calculations and I mean if I'm
Magnus I'm happy that he's thinking
because the the position we have on
screen
um in the bottom right hand here that's
analysis right we might get to this
position the live board you see now on
the bottom right hand side but what I
was going to get at is down this
variation here where Bishop C6 is the
thread this Rook is hanging like this
move Knight C4 comes to mind is this
bishop is under attack this bishop is
under attack this Knight is attacked and
also attacking the Knight the queen is
here it's just getting so wild and it's
a position where you really have to
calculate every single detail and then
not only do you visualize it you have to
assess it being like all right this is
fine I mean this is going to be a mad
game now we could see for a second ago
it looked like the camera was blocked
because I think very often the other
players in the room they sense that
something is happening and very quickly
a group of player forms around the board
when something like this happens and so
what happened well Anish has recaptured
on C6 and Magnus going for Knight E5
and now Queen C2
so we knew where this game was going and
I'm very very curious to see how it
continues because uh these lines I think
they go really deep I'm only just the
wheels are turning right now in my head
but I think Knight B6 is more or less
forced because of the strength of Rook
B1 and this Knight being stuck on A4 it
will be lost if you allow Rook to be one
so it Knight B6 Bishop takes B7 Knight
C4 is the first one that comes to mind
because of the Dual threats of The Rook
on A8 or the hit or the queen and the
Rook on E8 so Knight C4 but like Bishop
A8 Knight takes A3 Queen's under attack
Bishop's under attack let's protect both
Queen C6 how do you evaluate this I see
now that the e-bel bar says even the
players don't have that but optically if
we just think about how this position
looks white has a bishop compared to a
knight and what has the better Pawn
structure for now uh I made Queen takes
C7 was also something to consider with
F7 hanging like in your head your
visualize this you don't have it on the
board you're thinking wait a second I
can't play this because there are all
these pawns hanging and I would
understand someone not wanting to get
into this position it is much easier
when you can make moves on a board take
them back make new moves take those back
finally find the right continuation and
then the engine is there to tell you
that you are correct the players do not
have that
absolutely ridiculous of course that the
engine just tells were zero zero is here
let's hope the game doesn't Peter out
but very very exciting and it is always
it's easy for the engine to say zero
zero but it is a very thin line that the
players are working uh Robert let's come
back here in a while I think Anish might
be taking a moment here to consider his
options and to figure out
um the complications and back to the
bird's eye view I'll let you talk us
through what we're seeing and maybe we
should check in with pregnant and the
next yeah I think we should definitely
check in the program on the game I mean
the other games are also interesting One
Forest and Report have swapped queens
and shanklined and grandilas are the
position that we talked about a long
time ago with the inclusion of that
f-pawn going up so I know you're liking
Niels position with the aggressive play
by him but let's go to prognanda against
Duda as Anish giri he doesn't look very
happy actually like look at him he's
thinking he's calculating but that is
not the face of a happy man no uh I
think you're always going to be on the
back foot first of all you're playing
the world champion second of all he has
just
sacrificed an exchange after thinking
for a long time from an opening he is
well familiar with uh and yeah no
surprise that Anish uh is looking
um I don't even know what the word the
right word to describe him is but he has
a lot of work on his site he certainly
does and I pulled up the game
between Prada Nanda and Duda and if we
actually go back a bit because we left
off at this position here uh where the
queen went to E1 and what Duda did was
force some trades by starting with the
move Knight to G4 it's a clearly a one
move threat attacking The Rook The Rook
comes back Bishop A6 Rook is under
attack again Rook to D2 and then Bishop
C4 so he recognizes his advantage on the
queen side this is Duda that is with an
extra Pawn here let's trade off my
Bishop that was staring at a center but
that was protected for this bishop that
was actually causing my king some
concern so we have a trade the queen
came to E2 The Rook drops back I like
Rook C7 you can bring it to D7 if you
need or you can double on the C file try
to take advantage of that and Fiona as
we get to the game continuation D5 takes
E5 was played the Thematic temporary
Pawn sacrifice that I mentioned earlier
Knight E4 would be a tragic blunder when
there is a queen in line with heavy
pieces and there's a whole
Force here on the D file you have to
watch out what happens when that pawn
goes out of the way Knight E4 allows
Queen takes E4 politics E4 Rook takes d8
white ends up a piece of head and
there's background Checkmate problems as
well so that would be a blunder so no 94
for you and that means that D5 likely
will be captured next turn in fact it's
interesting that both sides currently
have a weak back rank so that's always
something to watch out for we talked a
lot about you know newcomers to the game
in the opening we tell them to develop
their pieces control the center get the
king into safety get canceled
um but equally very often a good tip in
the middle game was if you get to the
end game is watch out for that back rank
if the pawns are on F2 G2 and H2
you want to make sure that your king
remains safe I think for these players
it's not a concern they're not worried
that they are going to miss a Checkmate
but it's something to always keep of
course at the back of their minds
especially when as you highlighted and
there is this triple
um this triple is it an alikaans gun
uh the queen is has to be at the the
bottom the bottom right then a reverse
alikaans gun as staring down the D file
what do we call that a reverse uh the
reverse I don't know maybe then you name
for it we'll call it the Fiona's
I don't know I I don't have a word for
it
Rick was suggesting alakyne's knife
maybe we can we can leave it to the chat
I'm sure they'll come up with something
good
I think we need to name it in your honor
because you you know you asked what it
was called and I don't have an answer
yeah well maybe there simply is nothing
and while we while we consider our
options do that considered his options I
did not of course go to E4 but retreated
to D7
and showing the importance of this Rook
on C7 because the Rook protects this
Knight so Queen takes D5 then the black
queen you can just move off the file and
then the Knight is free
okay so can we have a look I guess Queen
D5 is the natural move
very
Pawn is hanging I take the pawn and I
guess the queen just goes to C8 so this
multi-purpose Rook on C7 defends the
Knight it also defends F7 which is
really important here in the event of
Moves Like Knight to G5 that the Black
Knight can just move out the way and The
Rook is defending the king it also is
going for the back rank as you mentioned
it's a problem for white so this Rook on
C7 is a heroic piece
yeah it's it's funny it's a position
that if I saw this at first sight I
would think it looks so uh precarious
for black
um there is this pressure along the D5
there's pressure on F7 uh there's the
Central Pawn on E5 uh but maybe black is
just holding everything together
um do you think that is the case do you
think black has everything under control
I think so yes and it really is all
thanks to this Rook on C7 it's a great
great piece and one of the things about
this position is right now there's you
know kind of equality black is up a pawn
but that Pawn's about to be captured but
long term that's really how you have to
evaluate these positions because I do
like the end game prospects for black I
like the middle game prospects for white
because when you have an extra Pawn on
the side the kings are then that means
your king is generally the one that's
safer and you can try to attack the
enemy King but if we get to an end game
the kings are closer to the center which
means that this king is closer to this
Pawn on E5 and black can use the outside
pawns up the board as a bit of a decoy
say you're going to need to bring all
your attention to those that pawn that's
about to be a pass Pawn in which case
then I can operate in the center of the
board so with pieces on the board Pawns
in the center are great in end games
pawns on the flanks are usually very
very good
sorry Robert I was looking at the chat
there were a lot of suggestions a lot of
them were words that I wasn't even sure
I'm not even sure I'm familiar with them
but the last one actually made me made
me chuckle from drunken aim any kinds
say hello to my little friends
[Laughter]
that's pretty good
it's a little long I think we can be a
bit more concise with our uh you know
turns of phrase here but I like it
so yeah shout out to everyone uh in the
chat I think we can move on from here uh
Robert what do you think yes for sure I
think uh with four other games that are
still super interesting uh the Carlson
game is Just heating up but Niche is
trying to work through those
calculations that we were discussing
um reporting in Von Forest there are no
Queens on the board but only the queens
and a pair of knights have been traded
and there's so much tension in the
center there and then they gave it to
Mama jar of and yesapenko
it looks like the Knight has gone from
E4 traded for the night that was
previously on B1 but the center is
opening up that game is looking like it
can explode at any moment yeah maybe we
start with that and then we go and take
a look at shankland and gretn dalius and
I mean in this game here between my
mediara Vanessa panko we're still only
on move 11 which is incredible 26
minutes on the clock for yesterday panko
still has to make 30 moves Robert
yeah and it's also making me choose
between players I'd like yessa panko's
position like a move ago now I'm
starting like mamajaro's position again
so it's just been a really hectic game
and the Knight on H3 Fiona we asked
earlier we said I don't really like the
move now I get why it's there I told you
it would come to F4 if black takes what
looks like a free pawn and white takes
on D5 and black takes back in Comes That
Knight to F4 immediately attacking the
pawn on D5 and then black has to deal
with that pawn being under attack D4 is
also a potential Target so I get it now
that's why the Knight went to H3 it all
made sense all along we just failed to
see why
um no but I I really think that this is
a game that we could come if we came
back to it every other move we could
just be changing our minds every time
because
um it's such a wild position
white spawns the g h ponds far Advanced
the white king uncaseled
and it feels like just every move I can
change the character of the position
once again the bar is not is not phased
it says zero zero zero but I can tell
you I see panko is probably a bit more
stressed than that even if you told him
in zero zero I don't think he would care
he needs to figure out how to to best
handle this position I guess he wants to
avoid the Knight coming to F4 but that's
not so easy to do
and speaking of zero zero zero look at
his clock it's heading lower and lower
towards zero so he needs to start moving
this was White's eleventh move Bishop
takes D2 so yes to panko he needs to get
to move 40 and he only has 24 and a half
minutes to do that and Fiona this is
such a tricky position we're mentioning
this Knight on nature coming to F4 your
right black doesn't want to allow it but
with all the pressure in the center here
all these pawns attacking one another it
feels like you're gonna have to allow it
so my main question is does black yes
panko does he play E4 and use this long
Pawn chain to shut down the bishop or
does he say you know what my opponent's
king is not that safe and look at him go
he's about to take the pawn there it is
e takes D4 he says I'm okay getting
these double isolated Pawns in the
center or they might come to F4 because
there's still a king on F1 if that King
were castled and tucked away somewhere
safe I probably wouldn't want to go for
this but because the king's then F1 that
allows me to take the pawn in the center
and if we do see a trade on D5 then that
frees up to C6 Square the bishop can
develop from C8 and it's not like black
has nothing to do of his own yeah
absolutely I think the position is
probably still fine foreign
objectively speaking I am very very very
concerned for his uh his time situation
for me usually when I I don't know if
you can relate to that if you feel the
same way
um for me when the the amount of minutes
I have is lower than the amount of moves
I have to make that's usually when the
Panic starts kicking in and especially
so if there's as many as 29 moves to Max
then
I'm no I'm with you uh it's not fun to
be under the duress of time trouble and
there are so many things that need to be
calculated in advance and that's I think
the biggest difference between
commentating or just analyzing and
playing is you don't get to take back
moves so you know I can draw arrows
people can visualize this or try to
visualize it but that's the hard part
like visualizing and assessing at the
same time when you can't just put the
position on the board and one example of
this and I don't know the assessment I
have the eval bar but I don't have a
series of moves to back it up but one
example C takes D5 C takes D5 Knight F4
going right for this Pawn on D5 so I'm
thinking I'll play Bishop E6 to defend
it what about this move G6
I see the evil bar goes slightly in
Black's favor but not so much and the
point of G6 is your F Pawn can't take it
and I'm trying to use my pawns to open
up your king and this looks kind of
scary to me because if I take the pawn
on G6 I can think about H5 but I can
also think about taking this bishop here
and queen takes G6 and Black's King is
open and whites King is also in some
danger but that's the point is that
trying to figure out the exact way
forward in a position like this is
really difficult and you need to come up
with that answer before you get into the
position because it could just be losing
if you haven't worked it all out
absolutely and I expect who has plenty
of time on the clock still over an hour
to take his time now I think it makes a
lot of sense for him to try to calculate
a few moves in advance
um and use the time wisely that way but
we'll come back here after a short break
such an exciting game of course also
plenty of action in Carlson against
Anish so don't go anywhere and we'll be
right back
[Music]
welcome again
for bending here in the Dorp in Vegas
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I just want to say I know it's early
yeah that's early for all of us but Fabi
you're looking fresh no thanks Danny
chat Chad likes it man looking good
what about me
all right guys let's go run a show back
here we go
and Fabi this video series was great by
the way people love it
really do
by the way again dude you're
you're just looking fresh man I love
your new haircut it makes me good
[Music]
hey there how's it going
foreign
[Music]
the whole new me
hey Fabe Danny how's it going hey Robert
hey man
you know just trying out a few new
things here and there the day is
beautiful sun is out
cool
hey Danny yeah I forgot to mention that
haircut's looking real fresh on you
thanks man
cool appreciate it you serious
where's the guy got do I need to get
noticed
what are you talking about
I did it seems a little out of line a
little uncalled for
[Music]
you know you already can't spell chess
without what does he want
[Music]
to come back here Robert I recognize
that red jumper but how fresh is the
trim
well thank you Fiona I'm glad at least
somebody can give me a compliment and
can recognize because I wasn't getting
it from Fabiano and Danny that's for
sure
well let's get back to the tournament
but before we do we have some great news
for you guys at home unfortunately this
year at Tata steel chess tournament
again couldn't have any amateur groups
or Spectators but you can all get
involved online on January the 22nd and
23rd we will have the online edition of
our chess Festival this will be a
two-day online family festival with
various activities for young and old you
can participate for free you don't need
to register and there will be a wide
variety of activities you can take
online chess lessons you can participate
in an online football training from SC
Telstar you can get a virtual visit to
Tata steel you can get creative with
craft videos you can take a digital walk
through vacancy or you can play in one
of our online rapid tournaments so
really plenty of activities on offer
there should be something for everyone
so to find out more you can head to our
our official website Tata
steeljess.com Tata steel chess festival
and we hope of course to see you many of
you take part in the online activities
and even more so we hope to be able to
welcome you back here on site invitancy
next year but for now have fun with the
online activities and Robert back to the
around two action here
well it looks like the game between mama
jarv and yessa panko is following the
path we set it out for so that is not a
surprise Shanklin and grandula are still
fighting it out but a lot has just
happened in the Magnus Carlson game
because I see his Bishop took a knight
on D5 and there's that Queen on A5 for
gear so I think we have to go there A
lot has just happened and I don't think
it's good for a niche absolutely let's
go back there and apologize I saw in the
chat there's a couple of games like
Shanklin like van ferez we've been
really monopolized today by this Magnus
against the niche game as well as Mama
diarov again CeCe panko they have just
been vying for our attention but indeed
let's go back to Magnus and uh even from
the bar we can see that clearly
something seems to have gone wrong for
any so let's try and understand what
what that is well I I see it I'm just
going to do the instant replay Knight D5
whoop there goes the bar and the problem
for black is the queen is caught so
after Rook B1 Queen A5 Magnus played
Bishop takes D5 and the bar actually
went down quite a bit so I'll try to
figure out why that is but this looks
really good if the queen takes on D5
thank you very much for the second minor
piece for the Rook that has to be great
for white and if the pawn takes on D5 I
removed the defender of the B4 Square
the Knight was covering the square so I
think that is an issue that uh needs to
be dealt with is that this queen on A5
is in the wrong place the bishop B4 not
approved of even though it looks good
apparently uh there is in fact better
than that move but it looks really good
to me Majors Rook takes B7 I don't know
just take everything
so I mean all of this looks looks really
uh good and
I mean there's
again very few Alternatives we see a
niche on the camera who's who's looking
more and more concerned by the minute is
this your move of choice we take on B7
yeah I mean if this were to happen I
guess Rook takes yeah there it is going
up and up and you can't challenge the B
file because there's Knight C6 tactics
uh C7 is under attack Knight C6 actually
almost traps the queen queen E1 check is
nothing the king comes to G2 the White
Queen can come up into the game and F5
and hit F7 I mean all of this is a
problem for black there are too many
issues to count so I wonder why the
engine is not so fun the bishop takes D5
because it looks good and you know what
it might be Fiona is that somehow and
this is it happens and doing so much
commentary that Bishop E4 which
threatens checkmate by taking on H7 and
then going for the mate like a move like
Bishop E4 sometimes you make that move
first because you induce a weakness and
then you take on D5 like that is that's
how chess works it's not really human I
would never think to play Bishop E4
because I would just take on D5 and try
to win some material but I think that a
move like this could make it even listen
to your own advice just stop one square
short oh my favorite tactic exactly stop
one square short of the expected move
and then go for a Checkmate because the
real thing that happens here is if black
plays F5 or G6 to stop the mating attack
just to show The Mating attack it's
Bishop H7 and Knight takes F7 check and
mate the queen defends here the bishop
covered FH the king could go there and
so all the squares are underwise control
um so if you play a move like G6 or F5
to stop that then I take on D5 and
you've created a weakness in Black's
position so
I these computers they make everything
seem so easy chess is difficult
sometimes all right Magnus Carlson is
amazing and he went Bishop takes D5
because it's still a very very good move
and a niche I mean is thinking about
that I was just gonna say Bishop E4
looked very nice uh with that with that
cute dark mating pattern but if we look
at the Danish cam uh it looks like
Bishop D5 also is strong enough Anish
this is the unhappiest we've seen him in
this tournament so far
um there's clearly something I mean
maybe we can go back and find out where
exactly did he go wrong because
um we see him there shaking uh shaking
his head
and they're visibly very unhappy our
producers and our camera people are
holding nothing back they are zooming in
onto a man who does not seem very happy
so uh that's you know TV quality for you
everybody
our their pain is our I was gonna say
entertainment but that's probably too
too harsh a little schadenfreude here I
mean yeah he looks very upset and I
understand why and I think he just
completely overlooked the move that
Magnus just played and I get it because
Bishop takes D5 giving up your fian
Caton Bishop like this seems to be
antithetical to what Magnus has been
going for if we just scroll back a few
moves to this position right here this
bishop aiming towards B7 like that is
the piece so to give up that Bishop for
a knight on D5 that's not what you
anticipate happening because you're
going with the the how the position has
been going you're thinking about wait
look at how things have developed here
that Bishop is super strong so you don't
suspect that in this continuation here
that the move would be Bishop takes
Knight on D5 and it's so good because
again the B4 square is available for
this bishop that's going to be a problem
for black and many lines we talked about
Rook takes B7 and then following with
Bishop B4 which will trap the queen and
if you take on D5 with the queen down
goes your knight on A4 and you can get a
second Pawn a rook in a couple pawns but
it's not sufficient I mean Black's King
is actually in quite a deal danger
eventually with the F7 Square being
threatened and I think I mean that I was
looking at the at the chat and you know
people are saying the position is not
lost for a niche and I think that's true
but I think the problem uh why Anish is
looking the way he does is
um it's not lost but it's bad and you're
playing Magnus Carlsen the best player
in the world and very often uh the
position if it's bad it's often just the
same as being lost
right and the evaluation isn't exactly
that helpful here because uh we know
white is better Anish knows that Magnus
is better Magnus knows his position is
very good and plus one in some positions
actually isn't that much especially in
closed positions where you have to find
a way to crash through and it's like you
know you don't find that way and just
equal here it's like Hawaii's gonna have
a bunch of ways to sustain that
advantage and there's pawns on B7 C7
that are under attack and if you look at
a niche it's almost like he realizes
that the game is going to go magnus's
way I mean he needs to dig deep he needs
to fight we saw Sam Shanklin put up such
resistance yesterday against a credit to
visit for winning once more but Sam made
his life so challenging and that's what
Anish needs a Channel right now he needs
to get into this all right I'm worse but
I'm not lost just yet let me figure out
a way how to make magnus's life
difficult but Bishop takes D5 has caught
him off guard and he is very upset about
the current position speaking of which
before we move on from this game Robert
I'm going to ask this question to you a
great question from the chat you're
talking about and putting up maximum
resistance from here great question for
my new soft lyrics what is the best move
here
what is the best move for a niche yeah
I mean Pawn takes D5 Rook takes B7 which
uh looks really terrible and just to
show that once more because if this
queen moves from A5 this Knight is
hanging if the Knight just tries to save
itself by moving back down goes the
entire seventh rank you're probably just
going to get mated pretty soon if you do
nothing Bishop B4 traps the queen on the
next turn because the queen really has
no squares to go to so that's why Rook
takes B7 is so powerful everything in
Black's position is hanging and if you
take with the queen on D5 which is the
only other option that I see at the
moment then after Queen takes A4
this looks really bad
um it maybe isn't lost just yet
but you can't even take on A2 without
losing B7 and that's not a pawn you want
to give up so this looks uh I just
can't even volunteer too much here it
seems very very very bad for uh black
although maybe F6 here throwing that
move in is important just to kick the
Knight back before you start taking
pawns on A2 and things like that on top
of the problems with his position by the
way Anish still has to make 21 moves and
he's down to 21 minutes so that is an
additional problem but we will come back
here and see how much resistance Anish
can put up but Magnus is looking in
great shape and maybe do you want to go
should we quickly bring up the bird's
eye view see what's happening elsewhere
has appeared on on G6 okay let's go
there quickly and then we'll have to
check in with Shanklin versus grendelius
and report against the van Forest we
haven't been there in a while so let's
see if we can get everywhere
I just really love what's happened here
because Knight F4 we talked about this
variation Knight F4 Bishop E6 G6 and it
turns out that Andre has indeed
calculated all this because he played
Knight to C6 he ignored the pawn here
and that's really instructive because if
G takes H7 check that looks like a free
Pawn but once the king just slides over
to h8 this is an umbrella pawn it
actually Shields the black king from
many different attacks so this Pawn can
stay here for now eventually it will
probably be won by black and black has
an extra Pawn in the center granted it's
a double isolated Pawn but look at all
the harmony of Black's pieces and if you
ever take this bishop on E6 well good
luck to your king on F1 you see the
evaluation just go really heavily in
Black's favor I mean there's nothing
going right for white in a position like
this so I really love this move Knight
to C6 by yesopenko absolutely read with
you and well at the moment I'm not sure
how happy Shakira will be with his
opening experiment but of course there
is still the time Factor
um but yeah I agree as the pancreas
handled this great so far
let's see I think a lot more is going to
happen in this game but for now it looks
like black is taking over shall we
quickly check in with Jordan van for
waste and Richard report
let's do it and as we switch the game
over here we see that the Queens are off
a pair of knights are gone but otherwise
all the pieces remain all eight pawns
per side still the tension in the center
here neither side is flinching in fact
the last move was Pawn to H3 and just to
show how we got here Queen A5 A3 and
then C5 by Jordan to stop the move B4
the pawn on C5 can't be captured because
there's a loose Bishop on B2 so that's
what happened we saw a trade and uh
report decides to trade Queens as well
as the black queen was more active and
this is how we got to the position Rook
C2 and H3 so I mean Fiona first
instincts I'd see the eval bar it's
essentially saying it's an equal game uh
do you think that we'll see a split
result or is one side gonna play for
more yeah
yeah I could draw is quite likely I
would say
um but also here I mean to we're only on
move 16 which is incredible it's very
early doors still uh still 24 uh and in
Jordan's case 25 moves to be made with
only half an hour on the clock I think
the position for now is uh very even
but both of them are fighting players I
don't think the players are ready to
sign the draw and go home
so time will be invested and I think as
the time take that takes down of course
mistakes will be more likely to happen
so I think a draw is the most likely
result but I think there's also a big
potential for for things to to happen
here yeah and I think we need to forget
about first move Advantage because
sometimes when we're playing in
tournaments but I have the white pieces
this is a game I need to try and win but
when you're in the midst of the game
like we are right here no longer does
that matter and in fact I prefer Black's
position because there is a king on D2
with all the material that King could be
in some trouble right it could be in
some danger there could be some pins but
in the pure end game if the Rooks come
off the board then that King could be
very well placed we like our King in the
center because we use the King as a
weapon in the end game this is not an
end game just yet there's way too much
material to call it an end game but it's
a queenless middle game and you have to
wonder about those Transitions and
that's why I think the players are
taking so much time on the clock but
also on the board they're not trading
pieces just yet because let's say black
decides to take on D4 and then white
takes into the bishop on D4 and you take
with the bishop here which is not a good
move because the Knight can come here
and attack this bishop like these types
of positions where yeah maybe black is
doing well right now I mean as the game
continues and maybe E64 is better
because The Bishop's not going anywhere
I could see that uh for sure that this
is the type of thing where it gets out
of hand very quickly you think that
everything is fine it's equal it's solid
and you just make a simple trade and
then you see the eval bar go up for
white and then you also from a practical
point of view think I don't know what my
next move is and I don't know what my
move after that is going to be and
coming up with strategies is difficult
yeah so I think still plenty of life in
this position I'm curious to see what
happens for now let's move on from here
and maybe quickly check in uh with some
shankland and Nils Cornelius
okay that game is actually very exciting
I just saw the move H5 was played and
there's a king on H1 so we know that
NEOS would like to open the H file and
attack the king but if black plays H4
you have to imagine that white is ready
to play G4 as a response and the eval
Bar says of course completely equals
zeros nothing to be seen here but no the
players don't know that they're trying
to figure this out and if I'm meals I'm
looking at G5 G4 at some point thinking
about Pawn to H4 other ideas Knight
coming back to F5 at some moment going
for this G3 Pawn or the G3 Square to
plant my knight in there the real issue
Fiona I would say is that it's not easy
to have a pawn break and black needs a
pawn break pretty badly to crash through
and have a big attack and if things
don't go well in the king side watch out
for A4 A5 and white to try to break
through on the queen side get after this
Pawn open up the B file and put the
bishop on D2 to make it work and then
all of a sudden white could be the one
with the better position so black needs
to find a way to do something over there
on the king side my question to you is
if so it is currently white to move but
let's say it were black to move does
black already have some concrete right
so ideas here
that's a really great question I
don't see or we can just make a random
move uh like let's say A4
and the answer is well clearly it's
starting to like Black's position a
little bit here
um oh a lot a bit so there must be
something in the air and that's the best
way honestly as a commentator sometimes
you just make a move and wonder what's
the direct thread you see the move A4
going for this A5 plan but that means
you're not taking care of your king side
and I really think that maybe just G5 G4
and playing over here on the king side
makes sense because we can push forward
and try to break open the line create
some Pawn tension and open things up so
that's probably the reason why playing
on the queen side won't work out and why
Shanklin just put the bishop to E3 where
we talked about this Knight on D5 if you
can get rid of the nion D4 and also the
bishop can come back and defend the
white king as well by the way the chat
is going why let's go back to magnus's
game I'm not sure what's happening but
according to the chat
things are happening
oh well it's the position we
had mentioned and Bishop D5 was captured
by the pawn and Rook takes B7 and I
think this game might be over relatively
soon
I think Magnus Carlson is getting his
first victory in tata steel and
unfortunately for the Dutch fans it
comes the expense of their number one
Anish giri yeah and for Magnus I mean
uh they have a well-documented rivalry
which was friendly at times a little
less friendly at other times and but
there was this uh this little banter
going on at the opening ceremony and uh
for sure I mean Magnus
um
will be very very happy here today I
think they always had a bit of a variety
of jewelry uh going on
so Magnus of course happy to get any win
in this tournament but I think
especially so uh against Anish and it
all happened really quickly I mean we
spend a lot of time in this moment after
Queen D5 what's Magnus going to do you
had spotted The Exchange Sacrifice from
a few moves earlier we weren't sure is
it going to happen but it feels like
after Magnus played this sequence
starting with Rook takes uh C6 somehow
um black collapsed quite quickly from
here
yeah and I mean it came down to this
move Knight to D5 which turned out to be
the huge mistake and Knight to B6 uh
that we were looking uh earlier that was
the move that needed to be played and I
I wonder if what Anish missed was this
idea Knight to C4 and it's really
difficult to see from a distance and if
you're not considering all these wild
possibilities the game might just
collapse because this person really
doesn't look good for black at least
from the start C7 is hanging Bishop C6
is a threat we've talked about all this
uh it could be a huge problem for black
Rook B1 as well so that's why instead he
went for Knight D5 trying to close down
the diagonal and maybe he thought that
just Rook takes B7 was all that was
happening or I don't know exactly what
but Bishop takes D5 caught him off guard
and now here at the Rook takes B7 I'm in
this position uh in the game Fiona you
look at anisha's face that looks like a
man who is ready to resign and the there
won't be any trash talking I think that
Magnus is letting his game do all the
talking and you don't want to sort of uh
yeah when he's down it's tough of course
seeing uh Anish
um like this it's
been a tough game
um
I think Magnus from the side you know he
Unleashed what seemed to be some some
World Championship perhaps so it was a I
think from the start Anish knew it was
going to be an uphill battle but still
you don't expect things to
go downhill so quickly uh Anish also
yesterday was maybe hoping for a bit
more with the white pieces so um he will
have to regroup of course the tournament
it is a 13 round long tournament so he
has plenty of time uh to come back but I
think today Magnus is not going to let
this one slip
wow and he played C5 here and my first
reaction just going for checkmate and
queen F5 looks like it has to end in
disaster for black because you have a
knight you have a rook and then the
Queen's joining the party here
yeah C5 is the move of a desperate
player just trying to find anything at
all that might work but you know this is
look at this queen of five
you need to defend F7 because of check I
don't care what the evil bar saying
Queen if I was completely winning it's
going to go back up I feel very
confident about this it's a low depth
engine that once it starts think there
it goes see it's gone it's going to keep
going what do you even do after Queen F5
I what do I do well I guess I have to
defend the F7 if I don't want to get
mated
and then I'm gonna play Knight takes F7
and then my threat can be Knight H6
check opening up the seventh rank
everything here is a problem and queen
E6 can be played Queen takes D5
I have too many threads it's just over
yeah and I I don't see where black can
get any counter chances here
it's just
it's just I mean there's nothing that
black can do it's just obliteration at
this point
I mean it's kind of sad to see because
Anish has that kind of not just the look
but also the posture
um you know he's not really in in that
fighting like
if you just look at the camera it almost
looks like this is a game that is over
yeah he knows uh both players really
know that this one is uh done with
Magnus he has that look of a man who's
ready to pounce on his next turn you
know he he knows that he has this one in
the bag and he's I'm sure thrilled to
take down a niche and you said a rivalry
you know it's a rivalry on social media
on the chessboard it seems to be going
back this way and just like Magnus has
his way with uh all players more or less
but Anish did beat Magnus in the world
Blitz Championship the recently
concluded World Bliss Championship so uh
you know I'm sure that's on magnus's
brain as he goes to win this game
absolutely and Magnus well uh we talked
about it yesterday he announced recently
that one of his big goals is to reach at
2900 rating in classical chess yesterday
he was held to a draw uh by yessi panko
but today it looks like that's going to
be a big win for him with the white
pieces he sometimes had slow starts in
vacancy with a lot of drugs but Magna
said today really I think just a very
impressive performance
yeah
um
I don't even know what to say when
Magnus plays like this and he just wins
you know he just feels like there's
nothing that his opponents can do and I
like that you keep bringing it back to
the preparation and leftover prep from
the world championship because I believe
that's what we saw today and even if the
match didn't showcase this line it is
something that Magnus has had up his
sleeve and now he uses a nice exchange
sacrifice to defeat anishikiri it's not
over yet but it will be soon I believe
absolutely and I'm curious how much
Magnus is going to give away in the
interview and just how much he's going
to let us into how much of of what
happened today
um was this preparation we see Magnus
there uh looking looking surprised I
think what's happening in this position
he's just spoiled uh for a range of of
good moves here
yeah he wants to put this one away leave
no question marks and that's why he's
thinking he's also up so much time here
yeah absolutely I think uh in the way he
is enjoying this this moment right now
he knows that the kill is closed it
needs a few more accurate uh moves and I
mean Magnus is so experienced he is not
going to rush even if let's say his
first instinct was to to play Queen F5
as you say he has 52 minutes uh on the
clock and he's going to take the time to
double and triple check everything
and my main question is if he will
either shush the camera or wink because
Magnus you know he likes to follow chess
and he played the game against
anishikiri and I'm sure he saw the memes
and everything the tweets that showed a
niche winking at the camera after
beating Magnus at the world blitz so I
wouldn't be surprised if Magnus he does
some friendly ribbing and trolls him
right back gives him a little wink
I'm curious I'd forgotten about that
moment actually but there it is Robert
he moved Queen F5
is uh on the board
and Anish instantly responding way
through a cafe defending the pawn on F7
yeah defending it with another piece but
unfortunately after in each played C5 he
opened up uh the seventh rank so he
stopped the Bishop from attacking The
Rook on f8 but he did open and expose
that seventh ranks The Rook on B7 is
thrilled to be there and Magnus knows
that there's a knockout coming and I
think just a simple Knight takes F7 even
Rook takes F7 probably wins because
Black's King is so weak but I like
Knight takes F7 more yeah and I think
there he goes Knight F7 is on the board
and I I wouldn't be surprised if we see
a resignation
the body language is clear that a niche
is ready to resign so it's only a matter
of if he calculates a little bit and
sees that he has no chance but yeah he's
he's ready to resign for sure
so
the evil bar Sky High Magnus look I'm
leaning over the board we know he likes
to do that when he's winning and Anish
looks a bit slumped in his chair uh yeah
it is it is tough uh to see today was
really quite a one-sided uh game and I
think it comes back to what you were
saying in the opening uh Anish today is
gonna have to be very very accurate and
it almost feels like one inaccuracy is
all it took
um today One Missed idea by Anish and it
was game over
and brutally fast fashion
just great opening Choice by Magnus
making the decisions as difficult as
possible for a niche and so Anish never
really found his footing in this game he
was not able to find a solid position
even if he was trying to get one and
when he made that move Queen to D5
earlier in the game uh and it was met by
Rook takes C6 that exchange sacrifice
you could tell by how long it took Anish
to like play Queen takes C6 that he
wasn't ready for it like he didn't
prepare all this variation to begin with
but when Rook takes C6 happened Queen
takes C6 is the only move there and if
he was really anticipating that move to
Heaven he would have played Queen C6
without even spending a second
yeah absolutely I don't know if we
should stay here or just stay with the
camera okay we'll stay here
um what do you think Robert well like
will Anish make another move what even
is there
he might play Queenie one check or
something just to give a check but the
issue is I'll just draw an arrow to it
you give one check and the King goes up
White's next move is still Queen takes
D5 and your King has nowhere to go it's
in the line of fire smothered Checkmate
is being threatened so I I don't see any
way out of this situation for a niche
and thus give a check have fun with it
just to you know put it on the board now
Queen takes D5 here and you're King from
trouble I mean there's really little you
can do the seventh rank is open if you
I'll just make a random like Knight C3
so I can show the beautiful double check
and then after King to h8 Queen G8 Rook
takes and the king is smothered by its
own pieces and that is check and mate so
I I just think that there's nothing to
do here Anish knows it and maybe there's
no point of prolonging the game yeah
maybe what we can do is we can keep stay
here with the camera and pull up another
game what do you think
uh sure thing yeah I mean we uh
probably won't have
any or at least many more moves to go in
this one so let's see what we can find I
mean the game between
um Mom and jarov and yessa panko that
one has changed the deal here where the
Queens are off the board
Green's off that's uh that's a surprise
that's of course for me a disappointment
Robert so now the character of the of
the game has changed dramatically let's
go back and catch up with what has
happened
so Queen B3 was played after the capture
on H7 and then Queen D7 was jessupenco's
choice and one that was not really loved
by the engines you can see that black
according to the Eva bar had a huge
Advantage at this point I can get behind
that because uh black is up a pawn in
the center of the board White's King is
on F1 so
I I don't know maybe playing something a
little bit more aggressive was the the
way to go maybe even a knight to E5 type
of move getting that Knight active but
it's hard when two pawns are under
attack and if jesupanko realized that
Queen D7 just allows liquidation and
that he feels like he shouldn't be worse
here because why should he be worse it's
even material his D4 Pawn is well
defended uh this looks completely level
so he didn't want to take risk
especially because he had less time
which makes sense in a way it's almost a
little bit reminiscent of what we saw
yesterday a very exciting game petering
out as not too much risk wanted to be
taken after what has been an emotional
rollercoaster how do you evaluate the
position that that we see on the board
now yes it's pretty level I mean both
sides have their set of issues and
strengths uh the King on H7 is very safe
now the Queen's off the board The Rook
on C1 is well placed but the open e-file
is good for black and the net and F4 is
pretty good for white so now once a D3 I
was about to say it has a nice Outpost
there on D3 it's protected Square
um that looks pretty solid but I just
have to go to this Niche game with
Magnus once more because the last move
played is hilarious even maybe the queen
d8
because you can't take the queen without
losing your own so I just that I think
that's a funny move
um
that's very I don't know we don't see
that every day uh I still like your idea
of smothered mate what happens if I go
Queen E6
mini six looks like a reasonable attempt
but then maybe Queen
well not so reasonable not so reasonable
according to our bar yeah but even this
position like if we trade Queens because
there's no more smaller checklist double
check the King goes the corner but after
Queen G8 this queen still covers F7 so
this is just a huge blunder and you see
the bar hate it because the queen can
sacrifice in the blocks up a full Rook
um but
the problem still persist like even in
the event of a queen trade here
and you give a check on H6 and then
simply take this Pawn this king is not
safe you have a pass Pawn if this bishop
can find its way to the diagonal you
might get checkmated like that and
Knight F7 check can always happen so
this looks really bad for black anyway I
mean C6 can be played with the Rook
hanging
um I'm sure there's a better first move
than Queen E6 like what if I just take
immediately I'm sure that's really good
still but this is just honestly kind of
tragic for a niche and just to be clear
I saw a question in the chat as to why
are we laughing uh Queen V8 is the best
movie recording we're not laughing at
the move that it's just funny because
you don't see it every day that a player
voluntarily puts their Queen uh on
please uh but there is of course nothing
funny about it and I think it absolutely
makes sense for Niche uh to keep
fighting
and forcing Magnus to to just find a few
more accurate moves to um to get to win
yeah it's a fair way of putting it you
just don't see a move like because very
often putting your queen back to its
starting Square while your king is being
attacked and giving up your queen of
course the purpose being that the Knight
is pinned as well so it's a very good
move it just is amusing because of its
kind of Rarity
absolutely so
um I think we once again will keep the
players on on camera uh and we can go
where do you want to go Robert
um
we can go to the event Forest game
against report because we have seen a
good number of Trades here where
we left off was this moment and Rook E8
was played by Jordan like look at this
quiet move
I
just before we go to that move so we
will keep the players on camera and also
the bottom right board will keep on the
live position so you don't miss any
action there and yeah we're average
rookie eight
I mean look at this move you're putting
your Rook behind another pawn it doesn't
seem to have any point whatsoever uh but
there clearly is a point in that black
doesn't want to release the tension so
rookie 8 was played and King E2 was
chosen by report here neither side wants
to budge and then finally at long last
we see some trades and we're getting to
a position where the bishops come off
the board and it says it's slightly
slightly better for white at this point
but as I look at this position I guess I
would take with this Knight and the
reason why white is better is you
already have your rook in an active
place your knight is a bit more active
not there but here then I can come over
to square like B5 to cause black some
problems on the queen side and this Rook
can either double or come to a new file
so the Rooks are a bit more active the
knight's a little bit more active so I I
would take white here and it's a
position where if you're not careful as
Jordan you could get in some serious
trouble yeah absolutely I feel like a
little um what we call a massage is
coming up here for for Jordan who will
have to to defend quite accurately and
uh Richard clearly the one pressing in
this end game
um shall we check in with maybe pregnant
and Duda
okay here we go we have that game up and
it looks like a rook a queen lined up
could cause some problems but the not
enough f8 is covering a lot of territory
and if Rook d8 I guess black in return
Rook C8 and say you're not going to
Checkmate me because that's actually
funny that the threat is Rook takes f8
and queen d8 made not a Checkmate you
see too often Fiona absolutely that
would be very cute and but of course
Duda isn't going uh going to allow it
the question is how does he stop it
I think yeah Rook C8 would be the way to
go just to
uh cover the last rank so you know you
can't take on a fate anymore and if you
trade Rooks we're getting into that
territory that we've been talking about
a long time where this the pawns the
outside pawns are advantageous for black
so you have to be careful as white in
positions with few pieces remaining
because the outside pawns will distract
White's pieces to that flank and then
black can operate towards the center and
the King side absolutely so the position
might look quite equalish but still both
sides have their threads have their
ideas Robert we're gonna go on a very
quick break we'll keep Magnus on the
screen during the break and we'll be
back in just a few minutes
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
chest tournament the game between Magnus
and Anish Geary is still going on Robert
what were the last uh couple of moves
here we saw Queen dates and Magnus after
some thought decided to take on C5
he said it looks like a free Pawn to me
I might as well grab it the bishop
protects the pawn and also this diagonal
is now open so if the bishop can get to
the longest Diagon on the board that
will be a huge problem and C6 next will
threaten The Rook on f8
there are many issues here Fiona I don't
know which ones we should or shouldn't
address but there are many many many
issues yeah I think just too many too
many threats uh to deal with I think we
expected resignation already a couple of
moves ago but now also the time
is taking down unfortunately uh for a
niche and as you said just too many
too many threats looming the king is too
exposed
um
so we're really really I think we think
the end uh is near but I never really
um I never really want to
to
um to say that any player you know I
should have resigned soon I mean so many
times we've seen turnarounds so I
absolutely don't think Anish should
resign here but I think it will happen
oh yeah I have no problem with players
finishing the game at Checkmate in fact
I think that's often good for spectators
it doesn't feel good to be checkmated I
can say that having it checked man
numerous times but still like I you know
in this position there's no reason to
give up if you lose by Checkmate or
resign now you still get zero points for
the game and the big problem for black
is that this queen is still under attack
if you try to trade Queens with Queen F6
the queen trade is still losing and
that's such a huge problem just to show
a quick variation let's say we trade
Queens here and go C6 at the end The
Rook is under attack you play Rook to C8
to save your Rook yes I'm up material
and then white plays C7 and none of your
pieces can move this Knight is coming
around to D6 this Knight on A4 is out of
the game and or it's not going to be F7
into uh D6 as well but the point is that
black is just really crushed here what
if I try and bring my knight to B5 if I
I go Knight C3
to go at night B5 next
um
I don't know Bishop D6 is tempting to
protect the pawn bishop B2 oh gosh to go
for a Checkmate over here that probably
just wins in the spot because uh there
are issues here Knight could come from
F7 to D6 as well like just to
give this check and bring the Knight
around to attack The Rook but I see your
point like if you get Knight to B5 at
least you still have a chance that is
all you can ask for as an Anish giri fan
is like let me stay in the game long
enough to maybe come up with some
Desperado and
um you know Magnus is going to be
perfect he generally speaking puts these
games away with ease but this is the
type position where at least we can see
that black is trying to hold on after
move like Knight to B5 going after this
Pawn is gonna have to make up his mind
soon though four minutes on the clock
and we're still only on move
um move 24 in this game
I think it's gonna be Queen F6 what are
the alternatives
um
I I don't really see any that make too
much sense
um but I know queen of Stitch is going
to be losing as well
Rook C8 as mentioned C6 is devastating
for numerous reasons and yeah Queen F6
is indeed on the board
we expect Magnus to take the Queen's uh
off the board
well he and he could consider taking on
D5 but in those types of positions now
the Knight comes into C3 and at least
there's some faint hope for wait or no
the Knight of seven is not hanging yeah
because they work on the 8 let's show
that
it looks like you get this Rook but
unfortunately you lose the one in the
corner so you can't even take this
Knight so Queen takes D5 I guess
is possible but you see exactly it goes
down a ton and moves like Knight to C3
hitting this queen and then going after
this Knight are exactly why
so there's still some some live and once
again it's always surprising to me
although I I shouldn't be experienced
enough to know that it's never too late
to make a mistake
um it looks at first like if you take on
D5 that should be at the end but Magnus
he's not gonna fall for it he exchanged
the Queens on F6 uh but yeah I think
this was a great example again Queen D5
looked temperating looking down at the
King on J to Rook on A8
um but that would have been a big
mistake
and that's why Magnus too strong to make
that error although it would have been
an understandable one had he plundered
and he brings his Knight over to H6 with
check so they're following these forcing
lines the king coming to h8 and now C6
that should be just what the doctor
ordered here and yeah I do think C6
followed by C7 will be a big big problem
for black to deal with absolutely and C6
is on the board so Magnus making these
moves uh quite quickly now to work on f8
is hit at the moment as so we probably
have to move that but then as Robert uh
showed us just a second ago after C7
like will be pretty much paralyzed
yeah no fun and the Knight will just
reroute itself to 87 or D6 to kick that
Rook out of there and white will go on
and try to promote and I think you're
not even going to be able to sack in
exchange you're going to lose a full
Rook is black and that's why the eval is
so high
so and I guess there's no real
alternatives to Rook C8
um
trying to think I guess
not really yeah his gun Rook C8
and we expect Magnus to pushed upon 2c7
yes you want to save your lovely past
pawn and it does go to show that line
you mentioned if it was night to see the
reefer black that there is some work to
be done for White and the biggest issue
is that none of Black's pieces can move
so after C seven Knight C3 maybe the
move is Knight to F5 it's a knight F7
which seems a bit counterintuitive
because now I have seven check is
forcing and then your knight comes
around to D6 by playing Knight F5 I'll
give you your knight B5 and then just
play Bishop to D6 and say I'm protecting
my Pawn you can sacrifice a piece for it
but then you I have two minor pieces for
a rook and your king is and Grave danger
and if you don't take well then I can
even just move my Bishop back and or
play A4 and kick your knight away then
you know it's got nothing going for you
and if you take I just take with my
knight and everything's going right for
Magnus absolutely Robert while Magnus is
thinking let's quickly go to the bird's
eye view for Just a second I will keep
the camera on Magnus two games have
ended in draws if you're just joining us
now that's kayaking against dubov and
with it against Karana it looks like
Magnus Carson against giri will be the
next game uh to end and uh quick quick
look at the other four games Robert you
have about 30 seconds to talk us through
what's happening there
okay well the game between Shanklin and
Grendel is still very interesting I do
like the placement of shanklin's Bishop
on G5 the King on H2 actually looks
quite safe for the time being and I'm
still worried for black about A4 to A5
the Breakthrough on the queen side could
actually lead to an advantage for white
in Mama Jarvis yes a panko it looks like
things still remain level I like the
activity for yesapenko but I do think
that Mama jorv has good control and
protection of his pawns at least for the
time being in report against one fourth
I like the edge for report he is
slightly better and Jordan can hold on
here but it's not going to be easy looks
are deceiving it's two Rooks night King
and six pawns aside but you know that's
not enough to just say it's going to be
a drug black needs to work for it
because White's King in the center is
more active and finally prognanda
against Duda that game looks very level
we talked about Rook d8 is an attempt
for white but the Rook can come back to
C8 trades actually help black as he is
the outside pawns so that's what dude is
looking forward to making some trades
park down is not going to make that job
easy and that's why I put H4 he might
even try to go for an attack from the
white side I don't believe in the attack
I think the position remains level but
we'll see how that game develops and we
know that Magnus is on his way to
Victory absolutely and well let's bring
back the Magnus uh game full size we
have the position on the board that we
just talked about a second ago with NH
playing and Knight C3 trying to fight uh
the best he can and we already talked
about the different options here
worldwide Knight F7 check Knight F5 and
Magnus with still plenty plenty of the
time plenty of time on his clock to
decide which way he wants to go and
actually none of the two moves Bishop B2
which we had also mentioned earlier with
the bishop now rerouting to the long
diagonal
and let's say D4 was played by Anish
more or less forced because there was
Checkmate on F6 if the Knight moved away
and now he brings the Knight over to D6
so he needed to be a little bit precise
he is going to go Knight D6 now
and he's going to be up two Pawns in an
end game at best for a niche right so
Knight D6 Knight B5 he's gonna take on
C8 and then beat D4 is going to hang in
the end even if you get C7 so this is
just too much extra material for Magnus
yeah and uh
so Anish is thinking now but
it's not just the two pawns on the whole
position does uh collapse here so maybe
we can
when we show the lines on the on the
analysis board briefly
sure I mean Knight D5 is assumed B5
rather is the move that comes to mind
trying to force a trade but after Knight
B5 and even if we get into this position
and play them by A4
all right you can I'm just saying that
even if we get to this position where
you steal the C7 Pawn white is up two
healthy pawns here those are the two
extra pawns and then they just go and
the Knight is sort of useless in this
position it's completely winning for
white at this point
yeah and this one I don't think this is
a position where Anish is going to want
to test Magnus uh for so much longer so
he's looking now is there anything else
uh he can achieve unfortunately taking
the pawn on E2 with Jack uh after King
F1 the Knight would be hit and The Rook
on C8 would also still
be hit so this is not an option uh so
unfortunately this end game to pawns
down looks like
um that's the best and you can get for
me
yeah it's unfortunate for him he doesn't
even have any sort of trick up his
sleeve something that can confuse Magnus
it looks like the best that happens for
him as he gets the C7 Pawn but Remains
Two pawns down and in that case it's
just a
sure victory for Magnus Carlson who I
mean honestly the opening was
interesting the way he played was
energetic and Anish just didn't seem
ready today for this opening if this
happened again say a week from now and
not necessarily in this exact opening
that was played I do feel like a niche
you know on a different day maybe he'd
be
more ready for this type of game but he
was not ready for it to get so wild and
Magnus Carlson happily will take that
Victory point and move on to the
tournament absolutely and I mean it's
also a warning to all of magnus's future
opponents in this tournament
um better be especially well prepared
against Magnus this time around because
clearly he has some some leftover prep
from the world championship match and he
is not afraid to use it
is you know it's funny because that's a
very common question is like how long do
people hold on to preparation for and if
you're about to play in a world
championship match you probably want to
save it for the most important event of
the year but Max won't have another
world championship match until 2023. so
there are of course a number of events
this year some great events that will be
happening in over the board classical
play in addition to the many events
online but why save up a a novelty or a
cool opening because there's no better
time than a game like this and Magnus
Carlsen showing that uh good opening
preparation and just good ideas more
than specific preparation can lead to a
knockout Victory absolutely I saw a
comment in the the chat suggesting a
game have a shot every time we mention
well it's offensive leftover prep uh it
is true we have mentioned it a lot but I
I think the reason we have mentioned it
so much today is because it is I think
the storyline of this game and well we
hope that we'll be able to ask Magnus
about it and and get his insights and
once again I'm curious how much he will
be willing to to give away
and that's the thing right you
oftentimes when people prepare at length
they don't want to talk about it because
they want to savor it and you know save
it more than savor it both honestly and
so that they can use it in a future time
but uh for you know Magnus here I we've
talked about this then sometimes he
starts a bit slowly in tournaments and
then when he gets that first taste of
Victory he goes on the tear so he's
winning early in this event and Magnus
Carlson's the favorite no matter what
tournament he plays in but especially
now that he's getting an early win I
think that the rest of the competition
is put on notice absolutely and
meanwhile Anish has actually gone uh
King G6
and Magnus not in a rush to take the
book on C8 but Conley goes King F1
activating his King also defending upon
only two
yes and now E3 is an option to try to
remove the guard of this Knight on C3 if
the Rook moves at some point white can
still promote and get a rook and pawn
for a night there's many options in this
position in fact if the Rook moves maybe
this Knight will just be captured like
Rook f8 Rook to safety and you take and
bring your Rook right down to B3 you win
this Pawn get behind your pass pawn and
you're still ready to promote with the
Knights Hollow and this is just
uh as losing as it gets yeah and uh
Anish by the way he's down to just over
a minute now still nine moves uh to go
it really feels like he's been
um you know thinking about uh resigning
for a while very often it's also just
some kind of inertia you just keep
making moves especially when the time is
ticking down
um
and another move has just been made the
night has gone back I believe to be five
okay
and Magnus is taking that Rook
and then he'll play A4
and you'll kick that Knight away from B5
and even if you don't kick the Knight of
neat immediately
if you ever take on C7 you lose D4 and
we talked about that ending with two
extra pawns uh Bishop versus knight
ending is just completely winning for
black now if it was opposite colored
Bishops we might have a different tune
but not here and this is quite simple he
did play A4
yeah a for underboard and we will now
get to this to the sun game where you
see our photographer Leonard Oates in
the background uh getting ready
um to capture I always find that it's a
tough moment that when I've taken plenty
of pictures at events myself and I know
the world and the media they want to see
the picture of the moment of the
resignation in a lot of these big
clashes but at the same time you do feel
bad as the photographer because the
players they can feel often they can
feel your presence they know you're just
waiting for them to resign so always a
delicate balance to strike
that's right in addition to all the
commentary you've done you've done
plenty of uh you know photojournalism as
well as interviews and it's really
difficult to interview somebody or take
a photo when they're losing or after
they've lost right so it takes a very
delicate balance it takes a serious
amount of professionalism and Leonard is
as professional as they get you know
he's been the photographer for so many
important events in addition to helping
with dgt board relays and all sorts of
other organizational Logistics so
there's the resignation
the handshake and poor Leonard I think
had just stepped away for one second I'm
not sure I hope he caught it but Magnus
Carlson winning his game against Anish
giri and it's a huge win for Magnus it's
nice to see the two players uh
discussing staying at the board for a
second to discuss a few lines
and
I'm trying you know when they speak but
you can't hear them and they're pointing
to squares I always try to translate
that and figure out what line they're
talking about
and it definitely has to do with this
exchange sacrifice in C6
yeah for sure
um I don't think we'll be hearing from
Anish today but I'm very curious what
Magnus is going to to have to
to say but a big win for the the world
champion getting his first victory at
this year's Tata steel chess tournament
and we see them but I mean it's uh it's
really nice and there definitely is a
lot to discuss there were a lot of lines
um a lot of possible lines with that
sacrifice exchange but even if I'm very
happy to see a niche you know smiling
and Magnus as well and to see no no bad
blood stare between the two players
If You're Gonna Lose a game early
I think it's best you lose to interrupt
you just for one second but we've also
just had another game finish and my
media fiance SE panko has ended in a
draw
okay well I'm gonna have to
oh gosh not again so
I have so much respect for both the
players and from the point of view of
this game it's been fascinating from the
opening but they
they agreed on a draw
ban the draw offer
Bannon like players can make draws if
they play it out and it becomes and draw
short but look at the position that we
have here as the final position and I
would for once would love to hear from
chat to hear what your thoughts are of
if this game has come to its logical
conclusion that this is all that it
should have been and there should be no
more moves so
I mean I don't blame the players the
rules of the rules and they can offer
draws
I don't play very much anymore so it's
not like I can say what I would do in
these circumstances
but ban the draw offer it is the worst
thing for chess the draw for
I I barely dare saying a word
I'm intimidated by uh by Angry Robert
but I I agree with you and there was
still plenty uh plenty to play for in
this position and yeah I think she's a
very reminiscent of yesterday's draw
between uh du buff and Romania
you know I'm just going through this the
full gamut of emotions here we just saw
Magnus Carlsen win a great game and
Anish Geary talking it out with him we
got to see that um and analyze briefly
and then we see this where it's like
wait a second if you threw me into this
to analyze which honestly I guess is
kind of our job description it's like
all right I see some pluses for both
sides the game can continue and then
we'll see who plays better but like to
just have the game conclude here I'm not
blaming the players specifically because
it is a rule that's allowed I think the
easiest solution is just remove the draw
offer if they make a repetition they
make a repetition then I can explain
that repetition to our entire audience
say these actually are great moves
because uh black threatens this and
white deals that threat while attacking
something else then they go back and
forth but to explain why they agreed to
a draw here I see the eval bar the
players know it's a level position but
they should still play absolutely no I I
agree with you uh of course but let's
move on from here let's go back to the
oh actually we'll okay let's go to the
birds eye view only three games were in
Robert I might have been a little bit
too optimistic with my prediction or for
the size of results
I might be too optimistic I said three
and I'm not sure we're getting three but
we might uh the game's still going on
pragnanda against Duda there's a rook in
the last rank but it seems like Duda has
everything under control a report is
slightly better against Von forest in
the end game he can bring his King to D3
and start marching up the board and we
still have action of course in Shanklin
and Cornelius
which one of the three games would you
like to Let's maybe start with James
grendelius I feel like that's the
position that has most life in it at the
moment
I completely agree with that as much as
I love end games this position is
looking particularly interesting and I
like White's position the king is
looking much safer on G2 unless there's
some kind of sacrifice happening and if
there is no sacrifice I think that white
can use the vacated D3 square that used
to be a pawn there I guess it went away
for a B5 B takes C4 but now the queen
comes at D3 the Knight can eventually
jump back to D5 that Brook can come over
to F1 I like the look of this position
for Shanklin but we maybe just rewind
rewind a few moves and see see how we
got here
sure thing so we left off around right
here
Bishop E3 was played Knight to F5
attacking the bishop and attacking the
pawn the bishop is defended by the
Knight so that's why he said please
let's take my Bishop I want to get my
knight back to D5 against a darksword
bishop
Queen D7 okay I see your threat there's
Checkmate on H3 once the Knight moves
out the way so King H2 and then Queen to
D6 was played which doesn't seem
approved of Fiona I mean it looks like a
pretty logical move to me to get onto
the same diagonal as the king but Queen
D6 for some reason is not what the
engine ordered
yeah it's once again very hard to
understand it looks like a natural mover
as you're saying looking down at the
King on H2 let's see if maybe Sam is
going to to show us the reason why Queen
D6
wasn't the best yeah yeah I mean I I
really want to play G4 in one move but
there's a bishop here so I'm wondering
if Knight takes even though we talked
about how we don't want that if you can
get G5 and G4 in and just blast open the
app file you make good use of your Rooks
that have been sitting and waiting for a
long time now to get in the game so that
didn't happen it looks like actually
that's what the engine wants approves of
this variation I understand though
because from a strategic standpoint that
looks bad Queen D6 was played but there
it is Bishop on G5 and now King goes to
safety B5 played because the Knight is
loose but this trade only helps White's
cause and as we get to the live position
oh sorry Queen D3 was in fact played by
Shanklin D5 E4 under whites control B
file open f-file not open Fiona I think
all of the Practical pluses are pointing
in White's Direction absolutely and this
position has seems to have turned around
quite a bit uh but time also still has a
role to play we only even move 28 uh
with the 13 and 12 minutes respectively
remaining on the clock for some and
kneels I think what we're gonna do
Robert is we're going to take a very
quick break now and then we'll be back
with all the time travel action uh from
this game as well as the two remaining
end games so don't go anywhere still
plenty to play for here in the second
round and we will be right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
my first memory would be being here with
my grandfather and my little brother
playing here for the very first time I
was playing in the amateur sections and
really desperately trying to get a get a
look at at the two players playing
foreign
would have to be you know if we uh well
winning here uh last year without
question
a couple of years ago we started getting
neural network chess engines
um into the into the Jazz world and I
really changed the game uh the way we
see the game uh very differently and it
has improved our understanding of the
game immensely so it's a very
interesting development and the way they
play chess is really magnificent so it's
it's very nice
have a chessboard at home so I like to
bring a chessboard to my tournaments but
um 90 of the work I think does take
place on my laptop and using technology
I always think that like the engines we
currently have they're like the
strongest there can ever be but they
keep on getting stronger so who knows
what's uh gonna come in the future
I've basically played in all of the
groups and indeed that just coming here
as a kid and now playing on the highest
stage is of course very special to me
[Music]
great to hear
from last year's winner Jordan van for
race who is currently defending a
slightly worse then came uh against
Richard Rapport and Robert is Richard
making some big progress here
well you know how much I love end games
and if Jordan loves end games too he
still will not enjoy this one too much
he's on the worst side of this end game
White's King is more active to begin
with White's Queen side pawns are also
doing quite well here because we see
that white has pushed the pawns forward
on the queen side which take away
squares from the Knight whereas White's
night is a bit more mobile so I do like
the look of this position for report I
think that objectively the game should
be held uh the king for white can March
up the board and can't be kicked out of
there one of the critical things just
broadly speaking about this position is
when to make pawn moves and that's the
hardest thing about many end games and
the best lesson I received and it wasn't
a coaching lesson it was a post-mortem
between gotta komski and Peter lekko and
they were talking about if one pawn move
was induced how would that change the
nature of the end game so I always think
about that if this Pawn were on H6
rather than on H7 what would that mean
well that would mean the G6 Pawn is
loose and that could be a huge problem
for black so the little pawn moves here
and there actually have huge
consequences and in a position like this
that is especially true this Pawn we're
on A6 maybe the cane could quickly jet
all the way over to B6 if this Pawn were
on B6 then the king would try to jump
over to A6 so little pawn moves make a
huge difference in these end games and
we just saw Jordan jump in with the move
Knight to E4 instead of touching any of
his Pawns yeah and Jordan I think is
looking uh quite nervous this game
although it looks like we're deep into
the end game uh the clock situation is a
problem here as well we're only on move
29 so still 11 moves had to go and
although the material is so reduced I
think especially because of what you
were just saying every pawn move is
going to change the nature of the
position every pawn move is going to
create some weaknesses they will some
holes will be left some pawns will be
left undefended and so very very tough
to
to figure out the intricacies of this
end game with so little time on the
clock
yes and I mean a good example of this
actually was even just like two moves
ago here instead of A4 uh White could
have started with Knight G5 check
forcing the king closer to this H Pawn
and then the king comes to G7 and let's
say white then plays A4
black would play H6 likely to kick the
Knight out but then you played the move
H6 and look at the evaluation Parts
slightly better for why there's
Improvement but I care less about the
evaluation more so about what that kind
of pawn move does to the position
whether it's weak in the G6 Pawn
um or just you know create other issues
in the position and it is that G6 Pawn
that's a Target because when the Knight
comes around to E5 eventually now you
don't have a pawn defending it so the
king from uh G7 would like to sit in the
center but if the knights on E5 then G6
would be hanging things like that are
really consequential in the end game so
he didn't play Knight to G5 check
instead just played A4 and brought his
King up I can't blame him for these
moves and it is an end game they don't
have too much time remaining but they
probably have just enough to be able to
consider all of the nuances here
yeah I'm I'm curious uh if Richard I'm
curious first of all where is uh
Jordan's light going or is that just
meant to say centralized for now I was
wondering if as white if I can somehow
bring my king let's say to D5 and then
sort of play A5
A6 try and just give up that pawn but uh
in order to get in with the King
it's a really interesting idea you can
start pushing all your queen side pawns
to do that and you need a square to get
into to infiltrate because right now you
have D5 but you don't have C6 D6 E6 or
C5 as well so you're going to need to do
something of that nature and I saw
people talking about prognandez game and
how he had no time left they met me just
made to move 40. I saw the position it
looks pretty level to to my eyes the
Queen's about to be traded so that game
should end in a draw very shortly
absolutely so I I Think We're not gonna
go do you want to stick around here do
you want to have a quick look at some
shankland
uh I mean the schenko game is definitely
interesting as is this end game I love
endgame so I could stay here all day but
the Shanklin game probably
Robert just as we we said it the drawer
was agreed so you called it uh perfectly
we see the players have just gotten up
from the board so pregnant and uh
against uh Duda has ended in a draw and
uh well I don't know what you think but
so let's start to determine for the
bottom seat pregnant
a great start for him he drew with black
against Anish giri and now with the
white pieces he tried to pressure Duda
but dudas prep was good and his play was
great as well so you know we saw a pair
of Rooks get traded and then we got to a
position like this where we said The
Rook can come to d8 for white it
eventually did but what black did was
just say I'm gonna bring my king G7 you
need your queen to line up somehow and
even if you get that the queen of the
Knight are attached so Queen E4 was
played Knight to D7 hitting the Rook
hitting the E5 pawn and dude it gave up
A7 to win E5 and it was simply a swap of
pieces the draw was agreed to because
after Queen takes Rook takes we have
three healthy pawns on the king side
these pawns will will be traded for one
another and then the game is just a
clear draw absolutely it's only two
games remain let's go to some shankland
and Niels grandellis in both games the
time is quite low and we're still around
10 moves away from move 40 but Sam is
still pressing and let's just go back a
few moves to where we left it off after
was it here Queen D3 that's right Queen
D3 is the last move
and it looks like Neil's you know fought
for the D file he gave up in the f file
goes for the open file here but Sam is
the one in control like all across the
board it's a position where some of
Black's pieces look good in particular
Knight on D4 but most of the squares and
that's the thing is squares are so
important in chess are controlled by
white and look at that move by the way
Rook d8 is a move that I wouldn't really
consider but I get it if you're trying
to fight for the D file and if you get
rid of one pair of Rooks then E3 can
kick this Knight out at some point also
with the Knight heading to E4 and the
bishop leaves G5 Knight G5 will be a
huge fork and then E4 also attacks C5 so
Fiona I have to say this position
doesn't look like it's going Nielsen's
way he had some some aggressive
intentions early uh oh Rook B7 played up
goes the eval bar and White's favor it
looks like all that aggression is not
not working out in fact white is the one
in control yeah I'm very concerned about
those weak dark squares around the black
king also I mean the black king doesn't
currently have any squares it can step
onto and the work on d8 controls the
background squares the bishop controls
the square on H6 and so I love your idea
I don't know can we play Knight E4
immediately and just try and bring that
white knight in
that looks really good I honestly wasn't
quite thinking about the king in the way
that you just Illustrated which is a
great point that maybe Rook H1 to take
on H5 and just go Checkmate the king
it's like the king really is in trouble
here it has no moves and the G6 Pawn is
pinned so after Rook H1
I mean this is a huge thing you have to
put something on F5
and
I don't think you want to play Queen F5
but you don't I mean
I don't have too many choices here yeah
Rook H1 I mean I saw the King was in
trouble I wanted to get the knight in
but I like his suggestion Rook H1 a lot
and Rook uh Rook H5 is not quite a mate
threat but pretty much
um so you you have to do something about
it but what do you do the king cannot
move you cannot defend the Paul on H5
what do you do yeah
um I guess something F5 but I don't
really like Queen F5 uh it doesn't look
great and wow there it goes up and up in
so I mean the Knight is going to come to
E4 at some point even a trade of Queens
will be good for white because of the
activity the pieces and the D5 square
and then yeah just to we should update
the names on the small board it isn't
Carson Geary any longer so we'll remove
that thank you to the chat
um so yeah Queen F5 and sorry Robert
no I just I mean the move Queen F5 is
like I've stopped your immediate threat
but the underlying problems still exist
in 94 I guess don't trade the Queens
just try to bring the Knight over to uh
G5 once the bishop Retreats it's
yeah there's also the third G4 to
take advantage of the pin Pawn H5 now
Fiona this is unfortunately for Nils
grendelius not looking too Pleasant no
and I wonder when Sam is still thinking
um
but I would be shocked if he doesn't go
work H1 maybe there is other moves which
are attempting the position is uh really
very pleasant for him now he understands
he's in control
um
and there might be other options but I
I'm really convinced by by work H1
I have an idea for black so Queen F5
really doesn't look sufficient as a
response but maybe Rook F5 is better and
a big reason why is that after Knight E4
just defending G5 is Rook to B3 and
black suddenly is causing white some
problems and I see the Eva bar Still
Loving White's position and don't
dismiss that white is doing extremely
well but you look at the position and
now all of a sudden black has play White
is down under eight minutes about to be
down under seven minutes and it look at
it actually the eval bar it's on the
edge here trying to figure out what the
real situation is and players our
evaluation function is not robotic we
get nervous we see our King on G2 oh
that King could also be unsafe in
addition to Black's King being unsafe so
I do like Rook F5 more than I like Queen
F5 because it allows black to counter
attack absolutely and Sam well if he's
looking at Rook H1 now he's probably
trying to figure out the complications
after work F5 after Rook B3 and actually
we just saw some shake his head he knows
I'm certain he knows he is better but
there are a lot of pieces uh left on the
board black is trying to get some active
play the white thing although it is a
lot safer than the black king there is
still a black queen only six looking
down the light squares looking to
potentially infiltrate yeah either via
this diagonal or via H3 The Rook on B7
is actively placed ready to come into
the white camp
so it's not a a position where it's just
a one-way train some while continuing
his attack has to also make sure that
the black threats are being neutralized
and I think although some is better the
evil bar shows it I think a lot could
still happen here in this game as now
Sam has dropped under six minutes and we
still have nine moves to go Robert yeah
this is a very difficult position to
play because a bunch of moves look good
and earlier we're talking about breaking
open the queen side to White's benefit
but now it's suddenly looking like it
became Black's benefit because if you
could put a pawn back on B6 like if you
just gave black a pawn and put it on B6
and close the file that extra Pawn hurts
black because white is going to attack
on the king side and so what black is
doing is countering down the B file you
mentioned the queen looking very good on
E6 I agree it ties the queen on D3 to
the C4 Pawn also can jump into H3 if the
king ever had to move so night
um E4 at some point is what white wants
but it does allow Rook B3 with Tempo and
that's probably what's holding Sam back
there was one more question in the in
the chat from uh one t sip after Rook H1
uh is it an option for black to go
Knight to F5
Knight F5 certainly possible or not good
according to maybe that was G4 yeah G4
looks really tempting because after G4
if you play Rook D7 like yes I'm attack
your queen unfortunately G takes F5 will
attack the black queen as well so uh you
don't just go ahead and win material or
like you know when the queen your queen
is also under attack so unfortunately
you can't get away with uh move with
Rook D7 so Knight F5 will not pan out
for black and Sam has just gone Knight
to E4 so no work H1
okay and do you see how quickly Neil's
responded by the way I didn't actually
like it I thought he was respond like
instantly but let me I think yeah I
think he did it so quickly that I missed
it like Sam's move wobbled the pieces
and as the pieces were getting back on
their squares news had already finished
his move Rook to B3 like as if he was
pre-moving it and it makes sense we just
talked about how uh the queen on D3 is
importantly defending the pawn on C4 and
Fiona there is one idea that I'm
considering here I love sacrificing
other people's pieces Rook takes D4 here
is fascinating to me because after Rook
D4 if you take the Rook you lose your
Rook so you have to take the queen and
now the D4 Rook has to take back C4 is
defended tactically because of Knight D6
so something like this leaves one in
charge
what did he he has indeed played Rook
takes D4 wow and staring giving needles
to the stair
s and news was not expecting it because
you don't hesitate even for a moment
when Rook takes DeForest played you only
have one move he does in fact take the
queen Sam takes back and this position
is actually quite miserable for black
the visual in G7 is terrible as
mentioned Knight D6 will Fork the queen
on C4 and The Rook on F7 if the queen
were to take if the bishop moves Knight
G5 is coming black has nothing
resembling any active play White
controls the open default a great
practical Choice by Sam Shanklin even if
the engine Bar says it's only slightly
better for white yeah and not easy now
I'm sure Niels would have preferred uh
the engine but of course the players
can't see it but for the engine bar to
be a bit higher in Sam's favor but to
have a bit more counter play a bit more
practical chances because now as you
said he is quite tied down I wonder can
he we can't even take on C4 I guess
because of the fork on D6
exactly
so what's that gonna be I think needs no
he didn't make a move yet
can we somehow try and I would love to
get rid of my Bishop on on G7 what if I
go
change it on H6 probably not right
because you're not even threatened to
exchange it right the night will replace
uh the bishop but Bishop f8 has some
serious uh intentions here because you
protect C5 which is under attack and
protect D6 which opens up Queen takes C4
I still think that white can just sit on
the position this Rook can come to D5
and things of that nature uh but I I
like your thought process there Fiona
because Bishop H6 at some point getting
rid of that Bishop probably will help
black in the defensive task but it is a
defensive task I don't care that you
have a queen white is well ahead in this
position you have a rook you have a
knight you control pretty much the
entire board at this point and so Niels
is really in trouble
should we take one second to quickly go
look at the end game see how far away uh
Jordan and Richard are from move 40 so
let's remind everyone only two games
remain this one and then for race
against report
and also here we're only on move 33 a
couple of Pawns have been swapped and
under five minutes as well
yeah it looks like uh the g-pawns are
off the board and not much else and we
need to think about how trades impact
positions it's just a single trade
Knight H4 will not win any material E6
will protect so I can't just go after
that pawn and he plays Knight G5 and H6
is not possible because Knight F7 check
will win this pawn and E4 now is an idea
I'm not sure if it leads to anything
real in terms of winning chances for
white but if the pieces get traded let's
say I make the move A6 and just to force
this situation here where white king is
more active is farther up the board it
says that it's just even but you need to
be absolutely positive about this if
you're Jordan Von Forest because you
can't allow the nitrate and then hope
that it draws you need to know that it
draws because of White's activity in the
position
instead Jordan he did not go for Asics
he went for uh for E6
and can we do the same thing here
that's the big question because it you
know judging by the eval bar which is a
huge help at the moment it seems that
black should be able to hold this
position despite White's King activity
so E4 is undoubtedly what the player is
thinking about but I I do think with the
series of Trades it should be uh just to
hold here like if we get into this
position even King E7 to start that way
we maybe trade on our own terms because
here you see exactly this this is
exactly the fear that a player should
have in these kind of end games where
you say oh it doesn't matter how I trade
pieces and then the engine says it
doesn't matter of course it matters it
always matters and it really does and
it's because the white king is more
advanced it's on the fourth rank the
black king is in the third Rank and if I
push you back some more in comes my king
I have moves to waste and black really
doesn't so black you know let's say H6
H4 H5 situation like this I go King D4 I
am pushing your king back and then my
king is coming to E5 then I can push
here and win this H5 pawn and then
that's like you know just to show what
that looks like is let's say I get this
position I just go and take this Pawn
then your king will have to stay over
here the white king will rush back over
the queen side while the black king goes
after this Pawn is used as a decoy and
white would win so
Fiona end games can be quite tricky end
games are tough and we see Richard there
uh deep in fog trying to figure it out
uh Jordan at this moment are down to
under two minutes
so if Richard wants to keep trying what
do you think is the the trigger the
trickiest attempt for Richard
E4 for sure and there he goes there he
goes and for Jordan just based on you
know we went through a line and we saw
that the evaluation went Sky High after
Pawn takes Knight takes he needs to play
King E7 that seems to be the move to get
the king to F6 and the reason why
there's a really big difference between
the king being on F6 and D6 and it's
that when the king is on D4 the
opposition restricts the black king
right this King takes away all forward
squares but if the king is on F6 if the
King goes to D4 the King has the F5
square a an advanced option so just to
walk through that is that once we get a
trade that after the King goes to E4 and
H6 H4 H5 now King D4 when the King was
on D6 the king had nowhere to go after
King D4 the king comes up to F5 and yes
we see that black is winning because
black gets to the pawn first so that's
the huge difference is the placement of
the black king but very difficult for
urine to figure this out he's under a
minute now and I think King E7 is not an
obvious move also white doesn't have two
swap Knights after takes on e4 and
Knight takes King E7 and white could
keep the knight jump into C5 or jump uh
jump elsewhere
exactly so it's not only the king and
pawning game you have to be worried
about it's if the knights remain and
white starts pestering some of Black's
pawns and it's really not easy Jordan is
spending his time here
he's you know really pretty low on the
clock and trying to work this out
oh the clock did good news for Jordan it
did just jump up for under a minute to
under under two minutes but yeah either
way very uh little time and uh Jordan I
think there is a lot of a lot of
pressure on him now
yes because you can even see it on his
face there's concern and that's actually
good not to be scared because you're
nervous about losing but in general
being nervous is good because you care
you're giving in your all and that way
you make sure that you remain skeptical
you need to calculate not just assume
and I think that look on his face is one
that he is calculating every single
variation and he's making sure that he
is not just going to walk into a losing
King opponent game if the knights get
traded it's on his terms the king going
to F6 rather than staying on D6 these
end games are really tricky they're
fascinating but they're beautiful just
how the geometry of the board is so
essential and speaking of beautiful our
producer big has gotten us a beautiful
close-up off the clock I know the Jordan
says a little bit hidden but he's about
to drop under one minute I think it says
one minute six seconds five four and
very soon we'll see uh we'll see Jordan
under
and there he goes so 59 seconds now
you're in under a minute so the clock we
see on screen is about 30 seconds off
Oh I thought we were just admiring the
A4 and B4 points because those are nice
Advanced pawns and they deserve our
attention too not just you know those
ticking seconds I like those pawns where
they are they're giving uh report some
good chances to win it's funny what
Richard did who picked up his pen sort
of giving Jordan the hint okay you don't
have too much time here and I'm ready to
write down your move What's it gonna be
and he moved his Knight oh my gosh he
moved his Knight because he saw that the
king and Pawn in game was losing and so
he moves his Knight but isn't H7 just
hanging wait seven minutes hanging in
that's why we see Richard's report for a
very surprised face here
H7 is hanging and
it looks like we can just take it yeah
you could take an F5 first and then take
on H7 and that's a free outside pass
pawn and I get it I don't want to be
overly critical because we were just
walking everyone through the
difficulties of that end game and when
you have an eval bar off the side
knowing from the start that it's
completely equal if you do something
that is so helpful but when you don't
know you're really think thinking like I
might just lose this game if I make this
trade so let's do something else not to
mention that E5 check was a winning
threat as well so you you know you
couldn't make a move like A6 or waste
time or H6 because E5 check would have
won so I get Knight D7 even if it's a
bad move exactly yeah I think what you
like if King E7 was missed then the best
you can think of is to give up upon on
H7 because you think that online other
end games just lose on this button
Richard well he still has a little bit
of time but I think he's reaching and
there he goes Knight takes H7
he's grabbing the pawn and he leaves the
enf pawns on the board I don't think
that's actually of great importance I
though you should always note
differences in positions where if you
took there's a symmetrical Pawn
structure if uh black takes it's not
symmetrical but it doesn't matter or at
least I mean pause the same file so here
it's all about the outside pass pawn and
actually Fiona one thing that is worth
noting is that if you're going to move
your Knight Knight D7 is very passive
maybe Knight H5 was just a better choice
because at least you're attacking upon
even though your Pawn H7 is hanging it
still says an advantage for white that
much is clear to me but that probably
was a better night move if you were
going to move that piece yes I agree I'm
surprised Jordan uh went back and I I'm
curious what his follow-up idea is now
after the poem on H7 dropped he's going
to have to try something something
active get the Knight back into the game
try and maybe attack some white pawns
um
but I'm not seeing it and
you can just play if yeah I think E5 is
on the board
okay so he's giving up a second Pawn
after Pawn takes E5
uh check and then he takes F5 and this
is I mean this is just a losing sequence
he freaked out he got really low on time
he was calculating that the the
exchanges on e4 and the real issue as
Fiona and I have been talking about is
when he was thinking about the nitrate
on e4 there are so many variations to
consider with pawns and A6 Pawn B6 Pawn
H6 whatever it is they were all actually
losing for black and so with little time
on the clock Jordan couldn't keep
calculating and now he's in a two Pawn
down end game and this should be a
victory for report absolutely especially
since we're on move 38 now uh so three
moves to go for Jordan but only two
moves for Witcher to report uh he is
going to for sure and we see on Jordan's
face he understands uh that he has
messed this one up
um so yeah Richard is going to be
holding on to those pawns until we make
move 40 and then the players will get an
extra 50 minutes which will be plenty of
time for which I preferred to figure out
how to convert this to extra upon
and it's still extremely early in the
tournament but Jordan was interviewed
and he said asked if it's realistic that
he wins the event again and he said not
realistic but you know he's not the
favorite and that's true by rating he
still of course has a long way to go can
still win the tournament but something
that he did last year was he rarely had
bad positions his preparation was
Exquisite he didn't lose a single game
if I'm not mistaken and here in this
game he was more or less okay especially
at the opening but then we got to this
end game where two Rooks and a knight
and then a bunch of Pawns and he was
worse then it got to a night end game he
was still worse and then it was the
point where he had under a minute left
and he needed to find a series of only
moves very likely and he couldn't do
that under the time pressure so uh it's
unfortunate for Jordan and his fans for
the Dutch fans it's going to be a
particularly painful day Fiona Anish
Geary lost Jordan's about to lose so on
they got a Dutch win in Vikings for the
first time in I think it was something
like 35 years but it's not getting off
to the greatest of stars I thought it
was even more but I I could be wrong but
yeah today but great news for uh for the
Richard report fans Richard today it
wasn't anything spectacular in the
opening you know no nothing crazy but he
just supplied steady pressure
onto Jordan who who cracked as sort of
at the last hurdle in this pawn and
Knight endgame
yeah and the King goes up to E5 trying
to win that pawn on F5 it can go up to
F6 uh but the Knight that's a weirdly
placed night for
uh for reports that's the one thing that
might cause him some difficulty here and
they haven't reached move forward it's
about to be his 40th turn and the
question is do you push the pawn to F6
or do you say have that pawn take this
Pawn you'll still have to deal with this
Pawn on H3 and if I bring my knight back
around towards the queen side I believe
that white can just win the game on that
side of the board by giving up the H3
Pawn I'm not sure uh if he should go for
that he can just start with F6 that
doesn't really change all that much but
I'm just noting that even if you lose F5
there's still H3 and that's what if you
go B5 and try and make the time control
that way try and gain a temper attacking
the Black Knight
yeah it looks good I mean it says it
went down a teeny bit but it's still
hugely in favor of white and yeah that
looks really good uh honestly most moves
that aren't huge blunders of a knight or
something are going to be winning for
white and it's all about you know the
fact that now black needs to stay on the
king side and then this Knight will come
over here somewhere and help out
and Richard well he still has uh what
just over a minute and he he just goes
for the immediate F6
yeah I think that's the smartest Choice
it just means that you can pass the turn
and you can figure out how to win next
because the best that black can do is
stop the pawn and then the Knight can
come back the next move and give up F6
like we're talking about so this looks
like a pretty straightforward victory
for report coming up
quickly go back to Samsung
see if they have made a dead time
control whoa one move to go and the
position has changed a lot once again
and the first thing I see is the evil
voice zero zeros if you're just tuning
in now below the players cam you can see
the results so far only one decisive
game Magnus Carlson winning his game
against San Diego
and funeral is the reason why it says
it's level is because of what you
advocated for you said as black I want
to trade those Bishops that's exactly
what NEOS was able to do and if this is
correct Sam is down to Mere seconds to
make his 40th move he did play Rook D5
and the eval bar is going in Black's
favor which I can't really believe this
happens in time travel and Blitz chess
but black was in such a poor position
earlier and now on Neil's gone deals his
40th move he's a chance to take an
advantage and it's probably because he
is an outside pass pawn and this queen
for Knight and pawn imbalance with an
outermost past Pawn is apparently good
for black the question is what do we do
I guess we don't want to take on D5
giving white at that pass deep on so do
we take on G5 that's what needs uh goes
for and the players have now both made
move 40 so they will both get an
additional 15 minutes
but yeah we see a new means they're
walking back walking away from the the
board and some head in hand I wonder if
Sam already realizes this has slightly
gone wrong and I as you say I think this
Apon is the the reason why
so I think the certain this is where uh
explanations are often more valuable
than uh pure evaluation and the reason I
say that is because when I look at this
position one of the things I'm wondering
about is we're going to take this all of
his Pawns in front of blacks there's an
outside H Pawn which if this Knight were
to go away and let me try to force that
somehow like here
just bear with me everybody as I try to
make this situation happen don't take on
E2 I know I'm giving that pawn away but
I just want to sacrifice this night for
this Pawn that's all I'm trying to do so
here takes takes so something like this
if we get this position and that's where
you're trying to visualize does white
have chances to make a draw and we see
the evaluation bar I'm less interested
in that I would say even without that
bar the problem is that black has some
past Pawn potential and White's pawns
are up the board in this manner if this
Pawn were on H4 then I think that white
has much better chances to hold even
though I still don't think necessarily
you're going to hold the game that you
can hold it much uh better you can you
know there's no past Pawn to make for
black The Rook can shift between G5 the
king can just maneuver like F2 those
kind of squares so that would give white
better chances but with the pawn
structure the way it is I think that
black would be winning yeah so an
incredible turn around here
um with suddenly black being the one in
the driver's seat
Robert we've had a lot of emotions a lot
of things have happened in this time
control only two games remain but all to
all to play for in this one and looks
like Richard reporters on his way to
beating a Euro invent Forest but we'll
have a look at all of that after a short
break so don't go anywhere and we'll be
back with the remainder of the action
from warranty
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
this year's FCC is going to be one for
the record books and one that people
will not forget anytime soon oh nice
from 4k5 love that C3 I love what chakra
is doing resilient that is right there
yeah that's incredible perfect play
that's just over and ding Ren all you
need to do was hold in the bullet he
moves on to the court of fines but what
a match this was done my head is
spinning and where's the mate Rook G7
look at this final position and this is
just insane this is indefensible with 10
seconds on the clock a king man
I don't see a move I don't see a move
and neither does Jeffrey he's not okay
this is over desperation but you can't
Crush anyway too many pawns and it's
gonna be a four point lead and your eyes
Wesley's incredible Ending by Wesley I
mean this is resignable and the worst
thing is that Neil is going to win this
with three seconds like he's gonna take
on D3 he's gonna go have five
and he's going to win the game
I'm speechless in our final score 18-9
nihal exactly doubles 300 report score
I'm watching the black Benjamin
somebody's gonna fly here
he's trying to give away everything oh
there it is Renegade Rook time but the
pro here's what what black is gonna do
Oh no you're gonna get I think I'm a
specialist in defending against it's
just King D6 and it's over already it's
over it's over before it began
he tried but Hikaru basically you know
in two moves played instantly just took
your idea and said yeah that's not gonna
work around here that's a really
surgical move you would never guess that
this came from a bug class oh my God
yeah that he just did it folks yeah and
Fabby
oh no
this is oh no we have our semi-finals
set Nakamura against Ding and nihal
against Wesley can you take him to a 95
again relying on that defensive Knight
oh look at busting I have no checks here
oh my God Bishop takes you for a 92
interposing with Chuck and what an
incredible win by Wesley he gets that
two-point lead incredible fashion Wesley
so wins the first semi-final
he's got five seconds he's gonna play
instantly in exchange here whoa Bishop
C1 7 he was going to D2 oh it was going
to be true but it was still bad Rook H7
check would have been terrible yeah oh
my goodness hicaro saves the match for
the win in the last game and we're going
to overtime oh beating oh everybody's
dream come true more games no ding once
checkmate
I don't know if he does he's got 12
seconds he's got no time I don't see the
win I don't know if I agree over the raw
we're going to we're getting we keep
going
unbelievable Hikaru survives
wilting c97 and B6 that is his only
chance to keep the sun give going he has
the time but he misses it he misses it
and he collapses Rook B7 King F7 King E6
yeah oh my goodness that but Rook a five
rookie the problem might be the black is
not gonna give up the E4 pawn and in
that case White's not winning that game
ding overlooked it ding missing that
tactical shot which would have given him
the chances and now he doesn't see a
movie Carl might pull this one out I
mean ding has to give up the pawn and
then move the Knight around Hikaru is
not losing this game he's got more time
on the clock and ding sitting back
basically admitting defeat and it's
that's it the match is over ding resigns
and Hikaru Nakamura wins the Armageddon
against England to make it to the SEC
finals Oh What A Move Queen
F5 on the skin of his team with a six
inches
[Music]
for the fourth straight time he wins the
speed Chess Championship with one of the
most commanding matches in SCC history
welcome back to the final stages of the
second round here at the Tata steel
chess tournament Robert what a round
that has been a lot of peaceful results
we've had drawn which draws between
visit and Karana between Mama di arafesi
panko between Prague and Duda between
karyakin and dubov but a big win for
world champion Magnus Carson against
Anish giri but all those drawers they
don't tell the full story
they certainly do not uh did it against
Fabiano that was well prepared game by
carwana he held the balance quite easily
dubov did the same against his
compatriot cardiac and uh pragnanda and
Duda they were trying to you know jockey
for a little something here and there
but nothing was to be and then mamajara
played G4 on move three so he has been
full of electric chess even if his
results don't really tell that tale and
of course we have two games still going
it looks like report is going to score
his bounce back Victory against Jordan
Von forest and Sam Shanklin against
Neil's grandilius that's anyone's game
at this point with a rook Knight vs
Queen imbalance absolutely interesting
that all four players who are still
fighting it out were all involved in a
decisive uh results yesterday and I
think I just think we might see another
two decisive results between the four of
them let's maybe start with the end game
between Richard to report and Jordan van
ferrys because I think very likely that
the game that will conclude first well
we can see the overview actually of the
two games
that are still going but the one between
report and when Forest is a night end
game with two extra pawns for white
yeah that one doesn't seem too difficult
for a report I mean look at Jordan's
face he's not exactly enthused by the
prospects of his position probably
because there really are no prospects
it's just uh all downhill but I have the
game between
Sam Shanklin and Niels grendelius in the
bottom right of the screen here it's a
position that is actually quite
interesting because in my first thought
was that black should be you know quite
a deal ahead here but then I started
thinking during the break Fiona that
it's actually Black's king that's in a
bit of danger and that could dissuade
Nielsen playing for a win so what I mean
by that is like Queen A2 hits two
separate pawns and after Rook D7 check I
could see a possibility that instead of
playing for a win you know says I'll
just play King G8 and go back to G7 and
we call it a day uh exhausted it's been
an intense battle because the only way
to play for a win is to bring your king
up to F6 and then bring your king up to
a square like F5 but you might be asking
for more trouble than it's worth
yeah it's uh absolutely true that I
probably underestimated that the dangers
linked to trying to push for a win here
um as black let's maybe show why the
black king cannot try and hide on H6
sure uh the king going to age six for
starters the Knight can just go to F7
with check and come back to G5 but
you're very close to being Checkmate if
I could have my pawn and F4 if you just
allow me to have it there then Rook H7
would be check and made so there's no
way you're playing for a win with King
H6 you're really just potentially
getting yourself in danger which is why
King F6 uh you're going towards the
center makes sense but after Knight H7
you don't even have King to f8 because
E6 because Knight f8 is check it
protects the Rook on D7 it also puts
pressure on G6 so this type of position
that's why Niels will have to calculate
right now because if he is going to play
for a win it's by bringing your king up
to a square like F5 and that looks very
risky I see an interesting question in
the chat from
leftw says I'm no Pro but I would be
considering Queen Asics for pressure and
defense
haha hitting the C4 Pawn covering the E6
Square from the check there it looks
like a very good move you're just
bringing the your queen back to defend
that does allow white to keep all of his
pawns whereas the queen on A2 hit two
separate pawns Queen A6 Only Hits one so
The Rook can come to defend the pawn for
example on either C5 or D4 and that at
least gives white some hope of
continuing this game and if black sort
of wanders and doesn't really do
anything of note this C Pawn could
become a dangerous one that black has to
deal with but Queen A6 is a perfectly
good move I like the move it sort of
holds Black's position together quite
nicely yeah absolutely and I think while
we see Nils has gone into the tank since
receiving his extra 50 minutes the clock
will update after he's made his next
move but I think is going to to be using
a fair amount of his time here to decide
um do I want to press for the win of
course he wants to press for the win but
then figure out is there any way I can
do so without taking too much risk
and what is the path I mean still a
hugely complex position despite the
somewhat reduced material
and Fiona you've done a lot of
commentary so my question for you is
putting you on the spot but I'm going to
ask you after a game where Niels was
much worse
um you know in real trouble and now he's
in the driver's seat or he you know he
doesn't know that for a fact but he has
a queen his opponent does not
he lost yesterday's game so if you're
trying to get into the mindset of the
player do you think you play for a win
to try to get back to an even score or
do you think that Niels is kind of he's
had a rough game today it's been
exhausting he just says let's call it a
day and go home
I think that Niels is uh quite objective
in these spots I think he's going to not
let what was in the past the fact his
decision
um I'm I'm basising my judgment also on
what we just saw on the camera Neil's
shaking his head I think if I just see
this person's back that's all I'm saying
it's a blackout
[Laughter]
um I think I think Niels is not gonna be
thinking okay it was a a rough day I was
under a lot of pressure let's call it a
draw I think if he feels
I cannot make progress without taking
too much risk and I'm not sure of the
ramifications then he might
um go for the for this potential draw
you were showing with the Perpetual
check
um but yeah I think Niels will will take
his time and make an objective decision
based on the position he is seeing right
now
yeah I think you're absolutely correct
he's a professional but he is a
high-class player and so he will just
try to decide if it's worth it and what
I mean by that in this context is that
I'm agreeing with you Fiona but he can't
calculate every single thing and he
knows that so if Queen A2 just to sort
of put that type of position on the
board again if he gets to this position
in his head and he's thinking wait is my
king in some danger like if this Rook
comes to E7 is my king about to get
checkmated you look at it the king
doesn't have G5 it doesn't have uh the
F6 Square so one check and it's made so
if you take a pawn you just lose the
game right you get checked and your King
has nowhere to go you have to give up
your queen and you're getting mated
right after that so it's really really
risky to bring the king up to F5 and
then you get here in your head reminded
everybody that I can make the moves
Fiona and I can talk about all the chess
and then we can say ah no let's go back
seven moves earlier and then you get
here and you're like okay I can't take
this Pawn I can't move my my king
White's next move is going to be C5 and
C6 and so on that looks pretty scary
from a distance right
absolutely
and I was sorry I was uh Nils did make a
move I didn't see the queen as well as
the queen now Queen E3
made the move and uh with a quick
accompanied by a quick stare at some so
Queen E3 is a move we hadn't really
looked at
foreign
it looks reasonable though you're just
applying immediate pressure on E2 while
defending A7 and
keeping the Rook on D5 honest because
that Knight on G5 is under attack but
you also do allow this Rook D7 check
because if the King goes back The Rook
just follows and if the King goes to F6
you got 94 with check the Rook can come
to D2 and this is
honestly a really interesting position
where there's no balance it's a queen
versus a rook a knight in a pawn Lasker
compensation uh for the queen and this
Pawn can start running up the bore the
sea Pawn just like the a pawn can start
running for black and how to assess this
is so challenging when you're just
trying to think about everything 10
moves 12 moves down the line and you see
a pawn race
absolutely I actually Robert the more
like looking at the two players I think
it's not unlikely we will see a draw
like the way Niels looked at them after
making his move and the way Sam is now
shaking his head because
I still think in this line after Rook D7
as black do you really want to step
forward
I mean the good news here is you can
step back let's say here but I guess
maybe Rook to D2 right away was better
than
Rook to D6 check you can save that check
for later it does looks extremely risky
and I think that's your point is that
White's Pawn can advance just like black
spawn can and White's King is obviously
safer than Knight The Rook they team up
very well here yeah I don't think I
would want any part of this if I were
Nils I would just make the draw fight
you know yeah because the Rook on D2 is
defending the pawn on E2 The Rook on D2
can never be chased away because it is
defended by the Knight which is
perfectly placed on e4 which in turn can
never be picked out the night from E4
and The Rook from D2 is doing a great
job also cutting off the black kings so
the black king can never help stopping
the C Pawn so
yeah I don't know if I would uh if I
would really want to try and play this
for a Winner's wide yeah it seems like
you're playing to lose rather than to
win from the black side and uh you know
the evaluation bar has stayed consistent
it says the black is doing just
absolutely fine but you just feel the
risk that one mistake from black in the
game collapses whereas for white it
seems like you have more wiggle room and
that's not a comfortable place to be if
you're Neil's granddelius so I I
definitely
a second what you're saying that here
there could be just a
a drop to Rook D7 King G8 and that's
what D7 has just been played so we will
find out now
um either uh Niels goes back and also if
Niels goes back I don't think Sam can
play either
um I don't think there's also any way
some can make progress without losing
any ground because the two pieces depend
on need to and the Knight on G5 are
attacked
I think it's the Neil's hands now is he
going to go back and very likely we will
see a repetition
and Nils instantly answers that question
and I think he stepped back onto G8 and
Sam immediately giving the check on the
eight so I think Robert we might just
see a handshake here yeah it looks like
it's about to happen and now Shanklin
has zero choice because you mentioned
the knight in the Pawnee two both under
attack so the king can go to F6 but that
allows the Knight to come to E4 with
check and then the Rook to retreat to D2
protecting everything so if I were news
I would spend all the rest of my time
calculating because he can make a draw
now or in 29 minutes and 34 seconds uh
or he can like think and just really
work at this position because the draw
can be had at any moment let's work
let's calculate and it's probably not
worth the risk just trying to be
objective about the position and as you
said Neil's a very objective player a
professional he had the black pieces
today a draw is a fine result it you
know he lost yesterday but today is a
new day and so is tomorrow so I do think
that you will play Kingdom G8 but if I
were playing and I weren't super tired
and I had some energy left I would be
spending all of it calculating King F6
right now and that's what he's doing
absolutely I agree with you the problem
is that you have to to strike the right
balance because if you use all your time
to calculate uh King F6 well then you
don't really let's say you spend 25
minutes now you don't really want to
play King F6 with only two minutes on
the clock because and then you're really
running a serious risk because also then
you cannot Forest the draw any longer I
believe at any point so
I think Niels will invest some time but
if you want to play you probably cannot
afford to spend up all your time before
making that decision yeah it's a really
good point and it's the difficulty you
don't want to play the move quickly
because it might be a bad move or a
dangerous move but you don't play too
slowly because if you do eventually play
it after calculating you don't have time
remaining to calculate the rest and he
did just play King G8 this game is about
to end in a draw the players will split
the point and I don't think either
player is particularly thrilled yeah I
was gonna say that I saw a comment in
the in the chat and there is the
handshake that it's a great save by some
I don't think that's the way Sam is
gonna be be looking at it I think Sam is
the one who was probably pressing uh for
longer in this game but in a way it's a
funny game where I think both players
will find reasons to be dissatisfied
and I think that Sam should be the one
who's more dissatisfied he had heavy
pressure down the D file on the black
king and it seems like there were a
series of mistakes that allowed Niels
not just to stay in the game and about
equal territory but then even have a
slight edge with the queen against the
rook and and Knight so I think that
there was a missed chance we can
actually revisit it at some point there
is only one more game remaining it's
between Rapport and Jordan Von Forest
that seems all locked up and no moves
haven't made in a while but
um if we do go back in time Fiona I
think after the queen sack somewhere
around here when you see the evaluation
bar it just loves White's position and I
wouldn't be surprised if you know I see
the eval bar go up I think tactically
Rook D7 might just be the tactic that
the doctor ordered because Knight F6
check there's a fork here if you try to
say that's a free rook so I'm guessing
and let's see Rook D7 stable oh
oh
go back up yes yes it's going back up
yeah Rook D7 uh is the choice of the
engines and the point is that after you
trade here it looks like a free rook but
that's a check and I get the queen and
then all your pawns fall
that's a very cute little tactic and
yeah I I definitely think that if one of
the two players it's gonna be some who's
who's more upset and I think it it was
even clear from the postmortem sometimes
you can tell like some walked away quite
quickly and uh yeah I think clearly uh
will be quite disappointed
yeah because when he didn't find that
tactic and he played Rook to D5 all of a
sudden the queen went over here and I'm
guessing there's still Rook D7 and
there's a huge Initiative for white when
said he played Rook D2 a quiet move
protecting E2 and then the advantage
just goes away and we saw what happened
at the end here there's nothing for
Neils to be worried about Rook F5 was a
pretty nice move because if you don't
play Rook F5 this Rook comes into D6 and
G6 is a problem and now the black king
is in serious trouble but said Rook F5
gets rid of the material and then we saw
the draw happen by repetition so I think
a fair result in the end yeah a fighting
game between two fighting players and
that leaves us with only uh Richard to
report and Jordan van forest and we just
saw Richard make a move on the camera
and bringing back that night
um 2g5 the players are moving very fast
King takes F6 Knight E4 check but it
looks like although we haven't looked
spent this game in a while that Richard
invested a lot of time
and maybe we can go back to where we
left it off but I wouldn't be surprised
if he has pretty much calculated this
all the way to the end from here
right so you're an F6 of the time Patrol
he then played B5 your suggestion and he
just brought his King towards the center
and that's when A6 happens so what
Rapport was thinking about is what do I
do with my knight and he said let's just
bring this on over and go Knight D6
check because there's a problem on B7
and this H Pawn still existing is a huge
issue for black because in some
positions you can sacrifice your knight
for the remaining pawns but here with
the H3 pawn it doesn't seem like you're
going to be able to do that and there's
no way to sacrifice the Knight easily so
it just seems like it's a tough
situation for uh Von Forest it has been
for a while and uh report is doing the
wise thing he is calculating he's not
just playing he wants to make sure that
he gets this Victory rather than wasting
an opportunity by playing a little too
fast
absolutely and yeah Jordan
well where do you go uh the king is in
check the king also has to to keep an
eye on the Black Knight on E5 so what
are your options the options are King F4
King F6 or King E6
foreign
all of them dropped this very important
B7 Pawn so
I can't show a mistake that white could
make so for example if we take on B7 and
take on B5 if you think you're going to
push this Pawn of the board uh and just
in general you can't allow black to
sacrifice the knife for that pawn if the
king is winning the H3 Pawn so you go up
a piece for white that's great but you
don't win the game it's just a draw a
lone Knight can't check man the king so
in this position you just take back and
then once the Knight comes to D7 you're
not going to ever allow your this Knight
to sacrifice itself for this very
important Pawn the king will be
distracted by the H Pawn and then the
knight and king for white will take care
of the Black Knight
yeah I think it's going to be a fairly
straightforward win for for Richard from
here King at 4 has been played
um I guess Knight B7
will be played
for sure
and I just don't see I think the problem
is exactly uh what you mentioned the
Black Knight will be tasked with trying
to stop uh the white beef Pawn but
because the pawn on H3 is distracting
the black king I think the the white
king and Knight will manage to cooperate
successfully to bring the beep on
forward
and it'd be interesting if this H3 Pawn
were not here like in this rather
position if this position is interesting
to me if we can remove the H3 Pawn in
our heads is this just the drawer can
white win this game and the reason why
it could be a draw is that white can
never allow the Knight to sacrifice up
for this pawn and that means the king
will try to work its way back to the
side of the board but it's cut off for
the moment so with the H3 pawn it seems
very clear and I like that move B6 by
the way because now you're leaving more
pawns on the board and that's good news
uh for white just so you can't even
allow like any hope of taking all the
remainder Pawns
and I guess Richard maybe just had to be
careful and we see the resignation there
by Jordan after a king to C5 so nice
technique by Richard he found an even
stronger move than Knight takes uh B7 as
a king C5 there's no way for black to
defend the pawn on B7 now and the B Pawn
is just gonna win so a nice victory for
a Richard report but a tough day at the
office for Jordan
yeah it's not the result Jordan was
looking for especially after the opening
uh there were no problems in his
position but little issues popped up
here and there after a series of trades
in the middle of the board and reports
showed why he is a top class Grandmaster
he was able to milk that tiny Edge and
nurse it into something that became a
bit bigger and Jordan was in some
serious time trouble he made a fatal
mistake and thus lost the game but
Rapport deserves so much credit for
putting the pressure on his opponent and
even in that last moment he found that
one last important choice in the end by
protecting his Pawn on B6 in advance
because had he played Knight takes B7
rather than King to C5 then there was
this move Knight to D7 and down goes the
B6 pawn and down goes the eval bar
because black is going to take the
remaining two pawns and then take to
kingside as well so this would have been
a decision that would have cost report a
half point and that's why he start with
King C5 because after Knight D7 King B5
there's no way to stop Knight takes B7
and the A5 Pawn Falls as well white
keeps the Pawns of the board and wins
the game absolutely nice technique buy
Richard to approach who balances back
from yesterday's loss in the best a
possible way I don't know if we have the
results ready for the day here they are
two decisive results today both white
wins one for world champion Magnus
Carlson against anishogiri and the other
we just saw it for Richmond report and
zurden Van Forest
so to this point we've had 14 games five
decisive ones and all five of those
decisive games were won by the player
with the white pieces so uh the first
move Advantage is real it's a
statistical thing right you get the Edge
by moving first dictating the action but
thus far in vikon Zay uh we haven't seen
a player with the black pieces win a
game even though in round one Mama jar
of did come pretty close absolutely
we'll see if tomorrow is the day so now
we're gonna take a quick break but we're
not done just yet so don't go anywhere
we'll be recapping some of the action
from today so we'll see you in just a
couple of minutes
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome again
for bending here in the Dorp in vacancy
fence over the Haley vehicles
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
it was a great day in Vikings day round
two is in the books and what a day was
this is your round two rapid recap Fiona
we had Magnus Carlson taking on Anish
giri the Dutch Hometown hero wasn't
meant to be was it absolutely Magnus
Carlson beating Anish Geary here in
vikanze for the very first time he told
us after the game very happy at two
finally leveled that minor score from
ages ago
and we saw him use a Catalan which we he
also used in the World Chess
Championship so maybe some leftover prep
we know he was vague about it but at
this point here he went Knight to A3
allowing the bishop to capture that
Knight instead of that move both Queen
C2 Queen A4 Knight to E5 all much more
popular but instead we see the move
Knight to A3 so Fiona maybe some of that
prep right absolutely maybe also some
influence from one of his seconds Daniel
dubov who loves to throw some material
around the board give up some material
and was part of the team during the
match against neponishi never scared to
be a pawn down sometimes even more and
in this game white remained a pawn down
for a little bit and this move A4
followed by Bishop A3 opened up some
lines for white and here is where the
game entered entered novel territory
because black could play Bishop to D5
but the problem with getting greedy and
just trying to hold on your Pawn is it a
move like Rook to E1 following it up
with Pawn to E4 something like this is
giving white the edge here and black is
not going to be happy to see this kind
of play as the bishop is kicked away the
pawn on C4 will be lost so instead of
playing for Bishop to D5 we saw Knight
to D7 and Magnus said you know what have
the pawn on A4 B5 was the threat so
finally Queen takes C4 played and there
goes that pawn on A4 Fiona and we can
see on the left hand side of the board
the time management Magnus was playing
all his moves real fast does once again
confirming that very likely this was a
position he was well familiar with and
for Niche a difficult defensive task
ahead from the very early stages
yes it certainly was because we had
talked about this idea of an exchange
sacrifice lo and behold Magnum says
Queen B3 getting out of the way of The
Rook Rook takes C6 now a threat removing
the guard of the 9a4 queen D5 was
supposed to take care of that but not so
fast says Magnus Rook takes C6 played
the Queens cannot be swapped because the
end of this variation down goes the
Knight and A4 two pieces for a rook for
white and a winning Advantage the bar
goes up so instead of this decision
Anish decides to take on C6 with the
queen defending the 9a4 but Fiona here
comes the pieces for white absolutely
and From This Moment onward we were
considering the exchange stack for a
while but the tides started turning real
quick Knight E5 opening up the Bishop
from G2 and very quickly the problems
became unsurmountable for Anita they
certainly were Rook coming to B1 the B7
Pawn is under threat the C7 Pawn is well
for good measure and this is actually
where the game got out of hand because
the move Knight to B6 could have been
played by a niche a very difficult
tactical sequence that arises after
Bishop B7 and Knight C4 hitting the
bishop on B7 yes The Rook is under
attack but so is this bishop on A3 this
is Mayhem the eval Bar says oh it's fine
I look at this position and say Black's
King could be in some trouble but of
course our silicon friend says Nah no
worries this is all under control but
instead a niche did not go for this
playing Knight D5 which I'm sure we can
understand because Fiona Rook B1 and
Bishop takes D5 that's not a move you
expect giving up your fiancado Bishop
absolutely clearly a move that took
Anish by surprise during the game and
here it started sinking in that suddenly
you miss one move and it's already too
late Magnus has taken the upper hand and
he's in the drive I received that's
correct because there you can capture on
D5 right back if the queen takes on D5
you lose your knight on A4 now it's two
pieces for the rook and the activity for
white that's a problem instead he took
with the pawn on D5 and it wasn't about
this night after all it wasn't part but
Bishop B4 was not the move he was going
to play allowing the queen to slide away
to B5 instead Rook takes B7 threatening
Bishop B4 which traps the queen The Rook
on the seventh rank is very dangerous C7
and behind F7 Anish tried his best and
Fiona we had a bit of a laugh not at a
niche's expense just because you don't
expect it but queen d8 All Things
Considered was the best defensive try
absolutely a move which looks funny
there is so much attack going on against
your king and instead you ignore that
and you play a retreating move with the
queen that puts the queen on priest but
the queen shouldn't have been captured
by Magnus he did not capture it because
you gave up your own Queen and suddenly
the attack is not as strong as it used
to be and black maybe has some chances
to survive here that's right it's still
better for white after all that but why
give up your queen when you can trade it
the next move after winning some
material Queen F6 played and this is the
last moment where Magnus could have gone
wrong he decided to trade Queens a great
decision we know that Queen takes D5
does not allow Rook takes F7 that would
be a blunder because the Rook on A8 is
loose Rook F7 Rook takes F7 down goes
the rook in the corner once the queen
takes back so instead the move would
have been Knight C3 first distracting
the queen away and then taking the
Knight F7 black would be able to hold
this but Magnus way too strong Fiona
Queen takes F6 and what wonderful
technique you display from here on out
absolutely he was just surgical from
here on out never losing control of the
position pushing his C Pawn to C7
restricting the blackworks then
activating the bishop along the long
diagonal and in the end going to capture
The Rook on C8 so beautiful technique by
Magnus
and the best that Anish could do was
take his Knight back and then win the C7
Pawn but when all is said and done
Magnus up two pawns and Nish resigns and
that was your round two rapid recap
so Fiona that was really a fine game by
Magnus Carlson he now joins the leaders
here in Vikings a with one after two so
the standings have been shaken up a
little bit thanks to two decisive games
what do you think Magnus at the top so
was Duda so is vidit what are we in for
in round three yeah well very
interesting standings already after only
two rounds nobody on a perfect score
Magnus will be very happy with the way
his tournament has kicked off do that
continuing where he left off in the year
2021 and with it one of the surprise
players but a very strong start from
with it I don't say surprise players
um in terms of his strength of course a
tremendously Strong place but he'll be
very happy to be joining Duda and
Carlson in the lead what do I expect
from tomorrow let's have a quick look at
the pairings
oh some good wood Duda against Carlson
we're just talking about the top of the
standings all right Fiona I'm not gonna
make you make predictions yet I'll give
you the night to sit and think about all
this but we do have some great pairings
in store for tomorrow I mean for example
Jordan Von Forest lost round two after
winning round one now he gets the white
pieces against the lowest rated and
least experienced player in the field
and Prada Nanda is a monster he is so
talented and he drew against a niche
Geary with black he drew again today
with the white pieces against John
tristav Duda so why should he be afraid
of Jordan van Forest there's no reason
but I love that matchup on the bottom of
our screen here absolutely we also have
the All-American clash between Fabiano
Carolina and Sam Shanklin then one game
I'm very curious about is Anish giri
against
I started with two draws but two crazy
games how will Anish bounce back after a
lot so a lot of interesting games once
again for tomorrow let's have a quick
look at the tournament schedule we will
be back tomorrow with round three uh
same place same time so games start at 2
p.m Central European Time That's 5 a.m
uh Pacific
and then one more round after that
before the first rest day on January the
19th
well it's been a fantastic start feeling
I'm really pumped about this event
because we're getting five decisive
results in the first 14 games there's
also a challenger section I actually
last night spent a little bit of time
looking at those games but there's too
much excitement in the Masters
Tournament to go look The Challengers
but I have really been loving the chess
there have been a few moments that I've
been very vocal about my disappointment
those draw offers let's get rid of those
please come on shock we are you're gonna
have to take it down to the wire but
really it's been such good chest
Fighting Chess I love the tournament
held in Vikings day it's I mean it's a
classic absolutely always such a diverse
uh field a lot of interesting players
and we're really in for a treat still at
12 no it's still 11 rounds to go plenty
more just to look forward to if you want
to get involved at home unfortunately no
Spectators are allowed on site this year
but check out tatash.com there will be
an online Festival on January the 22nd
and the 23rd with a lot of different
activities you can take part in so check
out our website and we hope to see you
there for now Robert thank you so much
for today it's been so much fun and we
will be back tomorrow with round three
[Music]
foreign